Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ja, beim letzten Ton dieser Klänge sollte klar sein, was heute passiert. Wir haben Mittwoch, den 28. Mai 2008, der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Und das heißt, es ist Zeit fürs Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf Fritz. Heute Ausgabe 135 mit Henrik und mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir haben zwei Stunden Zeit miteinander ein wunderbares Thema zu besprechen, über was ich mich total freue, weil es ist ultra spannend. Frank, was hast du los?
Wir wollen heute Abend über Karten sprechen und zwar über die ganzen Karten, die Plastikkarten, die ihr alle im Portemonnaie habt, in großer Anzahl wahrscheinlich. Das sind Karten, die üblicherweise im sogenannten ID1 Format sind. Das ist ein genormtes Kartenformat. Der Klassiker sind die Telefonkarten, aber eigentlich auch eure EC-Karten, Kreditkarten, also alles, was irgendwie diese Größe hat. Das sind die Sachen, über die wir sprechen wollen. Also wenn ihr nochmal so ganz andere Karten habt, wie irgendwelche Parkscheinticket oder sowas, das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Thema irgendwie. Aber vor allem soll es erst mal um diese Plastikkarten gehen. Da gibt es irgendwie welche, die mit Magnetstreifen funktionieren. Da gibt es welche, die mit Funk funktionieren, welche, die einen Chip haben. Das sind alles die Sachen, die wir heute Abend mal besprechen wollen. Und die Idee ist, dass ihr einfach mal in euren Portemonnaies und Schubladen kramt und da mal rausholt, was ihr da so habt. Und wenn ihr da neugierig seid, was das für ein System ist, wie das funktioniert, dann werden wir hier schauen, wenn wir das Internet anwerfen und mal ein bisschen unserem Erfahrungsschatz kramen, was das denn sein könnte.
Wir werden hier von Potsdam aus eure Karten auslesen.
Wir haben extra so ein Lesegerät, wo man dann durchs Radio durch, durch die Radiowellen, also ihr müsstest dann irgendwie die Karte in Nähe von eurem Radio legen und dann können wir das direkt auf dem Bildschirm sehen, was da drauf ist.
Stichwort war natürlich, dass du diesen Sound vom Lesegerät mitgebracht hast, weil ich den schnell noch raussuchen muss.
Ah, genau, das macht uns so schön. Das Geräusch, das ihr kennt, wenn ihr eure Karte in den Geldautomaten reinsteckt, so ein Lesegerät ist es. Da ist also einfach wie ein Tonmantgerät. Eigentlich sind diese Magnetstreifenkarten wie ein Stück Kassette aufgeklebt. Das ist nichts anderes wie Metallpartikel, die sich durch magnetische Strömung ausrichten. Da sind ein paar Bites, ein paar Zeichen draufgespeichert. Da werden wir später noch erklären, was das genau alles ist, was auf dieser Magnetstreifenkarte drauf ist. Also wenn es eine EC-Karte ist, die in Automaten reinsteckt und was auch nicht drauf ist. Wenn ihr gestern Abend Fernsehen geschaut habt, plus minus, da gab es mal wieder einen Beitrag über die Sicherheit von EC-Karten. Und da werden wir dann auch noch ein bisschen drauf eingehen, im Laufe der Sendung.
Wollt ihr eigentlich wissen, was auf den Magnetstreifen der Karten ist, die ihr in der Tasche habt, dann ruft uns an, 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt euch auch ins Netz klicken, chaosradio.ccc.de. Da steht alles, was man zu dieser Sendung wissen muss und wie man uns hier findet. Und wir versuchen mal zu klären, was da auf euren Karten alles drauf steht. Gibt es da eigentlich einen gravierenden Unterschied zwischen Magnetstreifenkarten, die total veraltet sind und jetzt Chipkarten, die total das neue Ding sind?
Ja, durchaus. Also Chipkarten gibt es vor allen Dingen zusätzlich in Klug. Magnetstreifenkarten sind per Definition dumm, es ist einfach bloß Speicher, da sind ein paar Bites drauf, die kann man auslesen oder es sein lassen. Wichtig ist, man kann sie eigentlich immer auslesen. Während Chipkarten im Prinzip klug sind, kleiner Computer im Mini-Format, so Millimeter groß, man gibt wie mein Kommando und der Computer entscheidet selber, ob er das Kommando beantworten will oder nicht.
Die sind dann per se auch sicherer, weil sie jetzt einfach übersetzt schlauer sind und selber sagen können, du darfst mich jetzt auslesen.
Sie können sicherer sein. Man kann sie natürlich auch so bauen, dass sie einfach immer auslesbar sind.
Die Antwort war sehr, sehr, sehr vorsichtig. Wir werden heute Abend eine Menge, eine Menge mehr oder weniger Spaß haben mit euren EC-Karten, mit euren Kreditkarten, mit euren Parkscheinen, mit euren Zugangskarten für die Mensa, mit Karten, die man sonst irgendwie hat, mit Zugangskarten in Hotels zum Beispiel, wo man ja auch manchmal so eine Karte kriegt, um in sein Zimmer reinzukommen, was da eigentlich alles draufsteht. Und können natürlich auch Fragen klären wie, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich meine EC-Karte oder meinen Führerschein, was auch immer in einen Zigarettenautomaten stecke zum Beispiel, weiß dann irgendjemand, dass ich gestern Abend Zigaretten gekauft habe? Wie funktioniert sowas? Wenn ihr sowas wissen wollt, dann ruft uns an 0331 70 97 110 und zum Thema Geldautomaten.
Ne, bevor wir richtig einsteigen.
Wir waren kurz bei der Geldautomaten Musik schon, aber wir können noch mal einsteigen. Kein Problem.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur eine kleine Veranstaltungsankündigung machen. Wir wollen euch nämlich auf die Datenspuren hinweisen. Das ist eine Veranstaltung in Dresden. Das ist eine CCC-Veranstaltung, wo es so ein paar interessante Vorträge, Diskussionsveranstaltungen gibt. Das Ganze findet am 7. und 8. Juni statt in Dresden in der Scheune. Das kostet keinen Eintritt, da könnt ihr einfach so vorbeigehen. Es ist eine kleine, gemütliche Veranstaltung. Keine Ahnung, 200 Leute oder so was kommen da. Es ist nicht so eine Riesenveranstaltung wie der Kongress in Berlin zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, sondern es ist eine der kleinen, eher familiären Veranstaltungen, die übers Jahr laufen. Aber es gibt auch dieses Jahr wieder ein paar ganz interessante Vorträge und Workshops da.
Jetzt kommen wir zum Song zum EC-Kartenautomaten und den Betrügereien, die da passieren. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Wir sind Hardfire im Chaos Radio auf Fritz Cash Machine. CASH MACHINE Cash Machine von Hardfy, Chaos Radio auf Ritz, Teil 135. Ihr könnt uns anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über jegliche Form von Karten, auf denen Daten gespeichert werden, von der EC-Karte über die Kreditkarte, über die Paybackkarte, über die Krankenkarte, über die ADAC-Karte, über die Karte in der Mensa, wo ihr euer Essen mitkauft, alles Mögliche. Wenn ihr schon mal immer mal wissen wolltet, was da eigentlich alles für Daten gespeichert sind und wo die Lücken sind, wo es euch um die Ohren fliegen kann, dann rufen wir das einfach an. 0331 77 97 110. Frank hat es eben gerade erwähnt, es gab gestern im Magazin Plus Minus einen kurzen Beitrag zu neuen aktuellen Entwicklungen in Sachen EC-Kartenbetrug. Also der Klassiker, mir wird die Tasche geklaut oder mein Portemonnaie geklaut, da ist die EC-Karte drin, irgendjemand räumt mein Konto ab. Dazu brauchen wir ja normalerweise eine PIN, also meine vierstellige Zahl, womit man an das Konto dann rankommt. In vielen Fällen ist es so, dass Leute, die PIN trotzdem irgendwie auf die Karte geschrieben haben oder irgendwo drauf sind, die Leute kommen an meine PIN ran. Okay, da kann man sich erklären, wie die an die PIN kommen. Aber es gibt auch Fälle von Leuten, die den Umschlag mit der PIN, die du von der Bank bekommst, verschlossen zu Hause liegen haben. Das heißt, niemand, nicht mal der Betreiber sozusagen, der Besitzer, kennt den PIN dieser Karte und trotzdem knacken die das Konto. Wie funktioniert denn das?
Ja, das ist die ganz große Frage dabei. Wir können es auch nicht abschließend klären. Wir haben bei der ganzen Sache so ein bisschen komisches Bauchgefühl. Es ist aber so, dass der klassische Betrugsfall, das sind wahrscheinlich nach unserer Schätzung 90 Prozent der Fälle, sind sogenannte Skimming-Fälle. Das heißt also entweder wird bei der Benutzung vom Geldautomat, werden die Magnetstreifen Daten, also die Daten, die auf diesem Magnetstreifen von meiner Karte sind, wir haben eben gehört, das ist komplett unverschlüsselt. Man kann ja einfach so auslesen, da gibt es irgendwie keinen Schutz. Die werden dann mit einem kleinen Vorsatz, der da heimlich angebracht wurde von den Gaunern, werden die dann eingelesen. Das heißt, ich stecke da meine Karte rein und in dem Moment, wo die Karte in das Gerät reingezogen wird, wandert sie eigentlich noch durch ein zweites Lesegerät durch, was da angebracht ist. So, und dann habe ich erstmal schon mal die Daten, die auf diesem Streifen drauf sind. Und dann brauche ich noch die PIN. Und da ist die übliche Masche, dass mit so einer kleinen Mini-Kamera, die irgendwie entweder auch in einem kleinen Vorsatz ist, irgendwie eine Metallplatte, die da irgendwie reingeklebt wird, über dieses PIN-Eingabefeld oder ein zweites PIN-Eingabefeld, also ein zweites Tastenfeld, was über das alte oder das originale rübergelegt wird, wo dann aber noch mal die Tastendrücke quasi kopiert werden oder irgendwie in einem kleinen Ständer für Werbung oder sowas, der neben dem Automaten hängt, ist einfach so eine kleine Mini-Kamera drin. Ich hab auch schon Fälle, wo einfach irgendwie ein Handy, so ein Video-Handy eingeklebt war, vorsichtig, in den Automaten oben, so ein bisschen versteckt natürlich, was dann einfach zwei Stunden lang aufgenommen hat auf eine große Speicherkarte. Also das sind so die Methoden, um an diese PIN zu kommen. Die wird das klassische Ausspähen davon und das ist wahrscheinlich die größte Zahl der Fälle. Allerdings gibt es da auch mittlerweile ziemlich gute Kulanzregelungen oder eben Entschädigungen für die Kunden, die betroffen sind, weil dann meistens auch eine große Anzahl von Kunden betroffen ist oder eine Anzahl von Kunden, die aber alle was gemeinsam haben. Nämlich sie waren alle zur gleichen Zeit an diesem Geldautomaten.
Wo dann nachvollziehbar ist, dass das Problem in dieser Kette an diesem Automaten sein muss.
Richtig, genau, man kann das also ziemlich gut. Es gibt mittlerweile ein bundesweites Betrugssystem, Betrugserkennungssystem. Das heißt also, wenn irgendwo was passiert ist oder wenn bei einer Kontrolle irgendwo aufgefallen ist, da ist ein Automat manipuliert worden, dann wird es an dieses System gemeldet. Und dann können alle Banken speisen ihre Betrugsfälle ein. Und das System hat dann über alle Banken grenzend hinweg so einen gemeinsamen Überblick und kann dann sagen, okay, da wird wahrscheinlich genau das Problem gewesen sein. So und jetzt haben wir aber noch einen kleinen, wirklich ganz winzig kleine Zahl von Fällen. Wir nennen es die sechs richtigen Fälle, also wie im Lotto, weil die Fälle sind, die eigentlich nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen. Das sind Leute, die tatsächlich diesen PIN-Umschlag noch zu Hause haben, noch original verschlossen. Die können, also die PIN gar nicht gewusst haben, können sie als auch niemand weitergegeben haben und schon gar nicht auf die Karte geschrieben haben. Und das sind die spannenden Fälle. Allerdings ist es so, dass wenn man mit so einer Geschichte zur Bank geht, das ist so, dass die Bank dann auch ziemlich unkompliziert diesen Schaden erstattet. Deswegen kommt es da auch nie zu irgendwelchen Gerichtsprozessen. Und bei den Banken ist es auch so, dass die normalerweise in dieser Kulanzregelung mit dem Kunden vereinbaren, dass er da also auch nicht weiter drüber spricht, also auch nicht mit der Presse drüber spricht oder sonst irgendwie großes Aufsehen erregt, sodass man von diesen Fällen also nie so richtig was mitbekommt.
Trotzdem sind die jetzt ja an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen.
Da gibt es jetzt Fälle und es läuft auch wieder eine neue, größere Klage der Verbraucherzentrale Neutron Westfalen ist das, glaube ich, die also jetzt nochmal die Sache angehen wollen. Die haben leider schon mal ein ziemlich großes Verfahren verloren vor kurzer Zeit, wollen aber jetzt, glaube ich, nochmal die Sache neu angehen. Und da sind wir jetzt mal gespannt. Tatsache ist einfach, dass dieser Magnetstreifen an sich komplett veralterte Technik ist und die Banken hätten eigentlich schon seit 20 Jahren das Ganze umstellen können. Es gab auch damals schon spätestens seit zehn Jahren gibt es Chips, wo man die Daten auch speichern könnte, wo also auch das Lesegerät sich dann erst mal beim Chip identifizieren muss. Das heißt also, der Chip weiß denn schon, ob das jetzt ein offizielles echtes Lesegerät ist oder ob das eigentlich nur irgendwie ein unlackierter Taschenrechner oder sowas ist. Das wäre also schon mal, zumindest für die 90% dieser Skimming-Fälle wäre das auf jeden Fall erst mal eine Abhilfe gewesen. Heißt natürlich erst mal nicht, dass nicht trotzdem noch ein anderes Problem sein kann bei dieser Pin-Erzeugung. Da gibt es also mehrere Angriffsszenarien oder mehrere Möglichkeiten, wo wir glauben, da könnte vielleicht ein Problem sein. Also eins ist davon die Erzeugung, wie diese vierstellige Pin eigentlich berechnet wird. Vielleicht ist da das Verfahren zu einfach oder es gibt eine Schwachstelle, wo jemand Daten oder Informationen rausgegeben hat, die eigentlich in den Bereich kryptografische Schlüssel fallen, wovon den Banken immer gesagt wird, die wären super geheim gehalten und vier Augen Prinzip und die kann niemand haben. Oder es gibt eine Möglichkeit in einem internationalen Banken-Netzwerk, also das ist dann, wenn ich irgendwie mit meiner EC-Karte in Spanien irgendwie Geld abheben will, dann geht es durch ein internationales Netzwerk durch, dass es da vielleicht die Möglichkeit gibt, mehr als drei Versuche zu haben bei der PIN, dass also da nicht richtig mitgezählt irgendwo wird, wie oft ich jetzt die PIN falsch eingegeben hab. Das sind alles so Varianten, die kann man aber als Außenstehender überhaupt nicht rausfinden. Und selbst normaler Gutachter, der vom Gericht in so einer Sache eingesetzt wird, hat da überhaupt keine Chance, bei den Banken soweit rein zu gucken. Die lassen da normalerweise nur ganz, ganz wenige interne Gutachter reinschauen. Dann ist es aber so, dass diese internen Gutachter in der Regel auch von diesen Banken Aufträgen leben. Das heißt also, wir werden auch schon aufpassen, dass wir den Banken ihr System dann nicht kurz und klein schlagen, weil sonst kriegen wir natürlich nie wieder einen Auftrag. Also das ist so die Krux bei dieser EC-Karten-Geschichte und das landet bei uns als Chaos Computer Club auch immer wieder und es schlagen auch regelmäßig Leute auf, die eben dieses Problem haben und jetzt wissen wollen, kann man diese PIN berechnen? Steht die PIN irgendwie auf der Karte drauf? Ich muss mal sagen, also nein, die PIN steht zumindest nicht im Klartext auf der Karte und es ist auch notwendig eigentlich, dass die Geldautomaten oder die Bezahlterminals eine Online-Verbindung herstellen. Das heißt also, dass auf der Karte eigentlich keine Informationen sein sollten, die irgendwie auf die PIN schließen. Ich sage mal eigentlich, weil es gab so 1997, gab es einen Wechsel des Verfahrens. Nach dem alten Verfahren war es tatsächlich so, dass Informationen zur Berechnung der PIN auf der Karte drauf standen. Nach dem neuen Verfahren sollte es eigentlich nicht mehr so sein. Allerdings, ich sage mal sollte, weil an diesen Datenstellen oder Feldern auf diesen Mangelsstreifen, die jetzt eigentlich leer sein müssten, weil ja keine Informationen mehr drauf sind. Seit 1998 stehen trotzdem noch Informationen. Und jetzt müssten die Banken eigentlich mal sagen, was da genau drauf steht und wie diese PIN jetzt auch wirklich dann geprüft wird.
Aber sie werden doch ein Teufel tun, das wirklich in der Öffentlichkeit zu erzählen, was aus einer Karte draufsteht.
Ja, dieses Verfahren nennen die Spezialisten Security by Obscurity. Das heißt, man vertraut darauf, dass niemand weiß, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Und dann wird das Ganze schon sicher sein. Das ist aber irgendwie ein Trugschluss. Das haben wir in der letzten Zeit häufiger mal wieder bewiesen, dass es also so nicht funktioniert. Das heißt, der beste Schutz ist, wenn man ganz offen erzählt, wie das alles funktioniert und es trotzdem noch sicher ist.
Und dann kommt der Chaos Computer Club, macht eine Sendung hier auf Fritz, das Chaos Radio. Und ihr habt die Chance anzurufen, eure Fragen zu stellen zum Thema Karten, Magnetkarten, Chipkarten, was auch immer, wenn euch da irgendwas komisch vorkommt oder einfach mal wissen wollt, wie die Dinger funktionieren, dann ruft uns an. Wir haben Zeit darüber zu reden. 0331 70 97 110. Bei dem, was du gerade erzählt hast, das Szenario, was du gerade gemalt hast, mit PIN ausgespäht, obwohl der Umschlag noch zu war, ist mir schon ein bisschen unwohl, als quasi auch jemand, der so eine Karten benutzt. Man hat ja gar keine andere Chance außer, also du musst ja irgendwie diese Karten benutzen. Kann ich jetzt irgendwie zu meiner Bank gehen und sagen, das ist mir nicht ganz geheuer, gib mir eine andere Variante?
Also was auf jeden Fall bei Kreditkarten geht, das habe ich auch gemacht, ich kann sagen, bei Visa geht das definitiv, ist, dass man die PIN sperren lässt. Also dass man die Möglichkeit, mit PIN Geld abzuheben für seine Kreditkarte. Nicht bei der EC-Karte, aber bei der Kreditkarte geht das. Dass ich einfach sagen kann, die sollen meine PIN sperren, die sollen das auch noch mal kurz in einem Brief bitte bestätigen, dass das so ist. Und wenn dann irgendwo ist ja hier Geld abgehoben mit PIN, dann kann ich sagen, hier geht nicht, habt ihr gesperrt, kann nicht sein.
Das heißt, du hast dann nur die Chance, Geld zu kriegen, wenn du wirklich persönlich bei der Bank aufschlägst und die legitimieren diese Abhebung dadurch, dass du vor ihnen stehst.
Ganz genau. Und wir haben auch viel diskutiert, ob es mögliche Alternativen gibt. Es wird ja auch immer mal gesagt, okay, hey, Biometrie, Fingerabdruck, Iris, Scannen, was auch immer. Nee, ist eigentlich auch nicht so richtig. Und die Banken machen es auch aus gutem Grund nicht, weil sie die ganzen Sachen auch nicht trauen. Es gibt ja noch die Variante, dass man auf so einem Feld irgendwie unterschreibt oder so. Der interessante Unterschied bei der EC-Karte ist, wenn ich damit pinne, irgendwas autorisiere, ist, dass da dann die Beweislast bei mir liegt als Kunde. Das heißt also bei einer Kreditkarte ist es genau andersrum. Bei der Kreditkarte muss der Händler beweisen, dass ich wirklich denige war und das unterschrieben habe und die Zahlung autorisiert habe. Wenn ich jetzt sage, nö, war ich nicht, dann muss erst mal der Händler sagen, ja doch, der war es so. Und dann ist aber der Händler in der Beweislast und nicht ich. Und bei einer Lastschrift oder so ist es so.
Das ist die Variante, wo man nur unterschreibt und keine PIN eingibt?
Genau. Da ist es so, dass der Händler auch wieder in der Beweislast ist. Also das heißt also, da muss mir der Händler im Zweifelsfall beweisen, dass ich das da auch war, der das unterschrieben hat und nicht irgendjemand anders mit meiner Karte da oder eine Kopie meiner Karte hingegangen ist.
Aber wenn ihr gerade gesagt habt, Henrik und Frank, dass diese ganze Magnetstreifentechnik seit vier Jahren locker veraltet ist und es eigentlich viel bessere und sichere Systeme gibt, warum gibt es sie nicht, wenn trotzdem immer wieder Fälle auftauchen, wenn immer wieder Fälle auftauchen, dass es da Betrügereien gab?
Also zunächst muss ich sagen, dass es ein Umstieg auf das sogenannte Chip-Verfahren heißt nicht, dass das Verfahren insgesamt automatisch sicherer wird oder dass wir diese Fälle gar nicht mehr haben, wo irgendwas mit der Pin komisch ist. Aber wir hätten dann auf jeden Fall nicht mehr diese 90 Prozent der Skimming-Fälle, wo einfach der Magnetstreifen abgefischt wird. Und das wäre schon mal eine große Hilfe. Und dann diese Chips lassen sich auch nicht einfach reproduzieren. Bei diesen Skimming-Geschichten funktioniert es so, dass es dann einfach von diesem Manipulationsgerät, was da dran ist, von diesem Stück Technik, was vor dem Gateautomaten klebt, werden die Sachen in der Regel per Funk irgendwo hingeschickt und von da aus dann gleich per E-Mail oder so was irgendwo ins Ausland nach Spanien oder so. Das hat den Hintergrund, dass Karten kopieren, also man kopiert das dann einfach auf ein Blanko-Rolling oder auf seine, keine Ahnung, Lufthansa-Meilenkarte oder Ikea-Family-Karte oder was auch immer rauf. Und diese Dinger funktionieren in Deutschland aber nicht, weil es bei deutschen EC-Karten noch mal ein spezielles Sicherheitsmerkmal, das sogenannte MM-Merkmal gibt. Und ein deutscher Gate-Automat sieht, aha, das ist eine deutsche Karte, da muss dieses MM-Merkmal drauf sein. Und wenn es nicht drauf ist, dann verweigert er den Dienst oder zieht die Karte unter Umständen sogar ein. Und deswegen, was wollt ihr jetzt erzählen? Ah, genau, also das ist das, ja, ich weiß nicht, das hilft mir nicht.
Wir haben jetzt sehr viel über EC-Karten geredet, angerufen hat der Jan unter 0331 70 97 110 und der hat Bauchschmerzen mit seiner Mensa-Karte. Hi Jan. Von wo rufst du nur an?
Aus dem Saarland.
Aus dem Saarland, grüß dich. Erzähl mal von deiner Mensa-Karte, was ist das für eine?
Also ich hab mich mal auf die Suche begeben von unserer Uni-Seite und hab dort ein bisschen gekramt, was das denn für ein Chip ist oder was das denn für eine Karte ist, wie die funktioniert. Und da ist die einzige Bemerkung, dass es sich um einen Myfair-Chip handelt, also dieses Ding, was in der CT beschrieben wurde, dass mal wohl die Verschlüsselung da jetzt geknackt hat. Und an sich würde mir das eigentlich kein großes Kopfverbrechen machen, aber dann hab ich nachgesehen, was alles auf dieser Karte gespeichert wird. Also das ist erstmal mir eigentlich relativ egal, Kartenseriennummer, Kartenfolgennummer, Gültigkeitsdatum und so weiter. Aber unter anderem halt auch die Matricelnummer und eine vierstellige Pin, die man braucht, um zum Beispiel Semesterbescheinigungen auszudrucken. Und wenn man also mit dieser Karte oder einfach mit dieser Nummer jetzt oder ans Internet geht und dann Matricelnummer und diesen vierstelligen Pin eingibt, dann kann man sich sämtliche Informationen, die die Uni hat, über mich ausdrucken lassen. Das könnte ja in dem Fall jetzt mittlerweile jeder machen, wenn ja die Verschüssung nicht mehr sicher ist. Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Naja, nicht so ganz. Also die Verschüssung ist gebrochen worden. Das war wieder das, was wir vorhin erwähnt haben. Es basierte vollständig auf Security by Obscurity, dass niemand wusste, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert, weil der Algorithmus selber zu schwach ist, als dass er an sich stehen könnte. Aber dieser Bruch gilt halt nur, wenn verschlüsselte Daten über, also wenn das Verschlüsselungsverfahren tatsächlich eingesetzt wird. Bevor die Karte irgendwelche Daten rausgibt, erfordert sie noch, dass das Lesegerät sich authentisiert ist im Wesentlichen das Einzige, was sie in diesem gesamten Verfahren richtig gemacht haben. Dass die Karte nicht antwortet, bevor das Lesegerät nicht bewiesen hat, dass es ein gültiges Lesegerät ist.
Das heißt, ich kann diese Karte nicht bei mir zu Hause an einem selbstgebastelten Lesegerät auslesen, sondern ich brauche ein autorisiertes Lesegerät der Uni.
Solange du den Schlüssel nicht kennst. Das heißt, du bist entweder mit einer falschen Karte, solche bauen wir gerade, neben ein echtes Lesegerät gehen, dann redest du ein bisschen mit dem echten Lesegerät, das antwortet dir nämlich, ohne dass du den Schlüssel kennst. Und dann rechnest du darauf ein bisschen rum und dann kennst du den Schlüssel und kannst alle anderen Karten auslesen. Oder du stellst dich neben ein echtes Lesegerät mit einem Funkempfänger und hörst einfach die Kommunikation von echten Karten mit dem echten Lesegerät ab und den Schlüsselstier anschließend. Solange du die Karte aber bei dir eingesteckt lassen hast und niemals in die Nähe eines Lesegerät gehst und solange dieses andere Verfahren, wo man einfach bloß neben das Lesegerät mit einer falschen Karte geht, nicht verfügbar ist, ist erstmal alles okay.
Aber die Dinger, die haben ja schon eine relativ hohe Reichweite. Ich muss ja nur in die Nähe von dem Leser kommen. Also das reicht, wenn ich das im Geldbeutel lasse, die Karte, und das dann in die Nähe von dem Leser lege, dann erkennt er das ja schon.
Die Reichweite ist auf 10 cm spezifiziert. Wenn man verschiedene Tricks macht, kann man vielleicht auf 50 cm gehen, sehr viel höher, aber nicht.
Aber also in der Praxis muss man sich da keine Gedanken machen.
Bitte wie?
In der Praxis muss ich mir da jetzt keine Gedanken machen.
Für die nächsten zwei Monate nicht, sage ich mal.
Oh Gott, das ist ja eine beruhigende Aussicht. Wieso, was ist in den nächsten zwei Monaten?
Na, wie gesagt, wir sind bereits und andere Forschungsgruppen sind auch dabei, solche falschen Karten zu entwickeln, die man einfach neben ein Lesegerät hängt, mit denen man dann den Schlüssel für eine echte Karte herausfinden kann.
Um eine Möglichkeit zu schaffen, die die ganze Geschichte noch sicherer zu machen. Unterm Strich.
Unterm Strich, um dafür zu sorgen, dass diese alten Karten aus dem Verzehr gezogen werden und durch sichere Karten ersetzt werden, denn die sind seit fünf Jahren verfügbar. Offensichtlich nicht bei allen. Ja, wie gesagt, die Myfair Classic Karte, darum geht es nicht nur einfach Myfair. Myfair ist eine große Familienbezeichnung. Die Myfair Classic Karte ist bei Universitäten sehr beliebt. Und das haben wohl auch kürzlich einige Universitäten das eingeführt. Wie gesagt, man sollte sie möglichst jetzt ersetzen. Du kannst nicht direkt was machen, was du, wenn du die Karte nicht wirklich brauchst, kannst du sie entweder gleich ganz deaktivieren oder du kannst sie zumindest in Silberfolie einschließen, damit man sie nicht mehr auslesen kann. Denn selbst wenn du den Schlüssel kennst, bringt es dir ja nichts, wenn du nicht mit der Karte reden kannst.
Beruhig dich das ein bisschen, Jan.
Also ich finde diese ganzen Sachen mit diesen Karten, wo man nicht wirklich weiß, wie die funktionieren und ob die geknackt sind, ein bisschen merkwürdig. Man kann sich ja nicht gegen wehren und wenn man was essen will, dann braucht man sie trotzdem. Ich hab zwar nichts gegen Technik, aber naja.
Wir versuchen auf jeden Fall heute Abend ein bisschen Licht in dieses dunkle Universum aus den Karten zu bringen, was du auch gerade gesagt hast, keiner weiß so richtig genau, wie die funktionieren. Wir versuchen das zu erklären, dazu ist diese Sendung da. Wir hoffen, dir erstmal geholfen zu haben. Tschüss, schönen Gruß in Saarland. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten, danach könnt ihr gerne weiter eure Fragen stellen zum Thema Karten, auf denen Daten gespeichert sind, von der ADAC Karte über eure Mensa Karte, wie bei Jan eben, über die EC Karte, über die Hotelzugangskarte. Vielleicht habt ihr auch irgendwie arbeitet in einem Forschungslabor oder irgendwas und ihr habt so eine Legitimierungskarte, wo man so mehrmals die vorhalten muss, damit ihr in Bereiche kommt, wo sonst keiner reingeht. Was steht da eigentlich alles drauf? Wir versuchen es zu klären. 0331 70 97 110. Nach den Nachrichten geht's weiter.
Der Christian Ullmann. Sind morgen Abend wieder in Blue Moon. Fritz, woher sollen wir das wissen? Der Blue Moon mit Christian Ullmann und Kathrin Thüring. Die Frage, mit der wir uns in den kommenden zwei Stunden beschäftigen werden, lautet... Tja, das hängt ganz von euch ab. Habt ihr unfassbar spannende, oft gestellte, doch nie geklärte und vor allem ganz schön verzwickte Fragen? Dann schickt sie per Mail mit Name und Telefonnummer an wissen-at-fritz.de und seid live dabei, wenn es wieder heißt, woher sollen wir das wissen? Morgen Abend ab 22 Uhr.
Mehr Infos. Die Antwort ist...
Mit Liane Gruß.
Der Fraktionschef der Linken, Gregor Gysi, musste sich heute im Bundestag gegen den Vorwurf verteidigen. Er habe für die Staatssicherheit der DDR gespitzelt. Mehrere Redner von Union und SPD forderten ihn auf, seine Ämter niederzulegen. Gysi sagte, man versuche ihn als Person zu beschädigen, um seine Partei zu treffen. Ihm wird vorgeworfen, für die Stasi einen Bericht über ein Treffen mit dem DDR-Regime-Kritiker Havemann verfasst zu haben. Deutschland will mehr Geld für den Erhalt der tropischen Regenwälder ausgeben. Auf der UNO-Konferenz zum Schutz der Artenvielfalt in Bonn kündigte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel an, die Bundesrepublik werde von 2013 an jährlich eine halbe Milliarde Euro bereitstellen, um das Abholzen der Wälder zu stoppen. Auch andere Industrieländer sollen sich dadurch ermutigt fühlen, sich für den Regenwald in den Entwicklungsländern einzusetzen. Immer mehr Milchbauern machen beim Lieferboikott mit. 95 Prozent der Mitglieder des Bundesverbandes Deutscher Milchviehhalter hätten ihre Lieferungen eingestellt, sagt ein Sprecher. Unterstützung bekommen die deutschen Bauern aus den Nachbarländern. Auch in den Niederlanden, Belgien, Österreich und der Schweiz protestieren Landwirte gegen niedrige Preise. Die Milchindustrie sagt, dass es trotz des Boikotts noch keine Engpässe bei Milch gebe. In Neapel wurde nach 240 Jahren die Monarchie abgeschafft. Das Land wurde nun zur Republik erklärt. Dem Beschluss dazu fällt die verfassungsgebende Versammlung. Im künftigen Parlament werden die Maoisten die stärkste Fraktion und somit vermutlich auch den Regierungschef stellen. Sie hatten die Monarchie mit Waffengewalt bekämpft. In dem Konflikt sind in den vergangenen zehn Jahren mehr als 13.000 Menschen getötet worden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Angermünde 17 Grad, Frankfurt in Europin 19, Potsdam Cottbus 20 Grad, Wittenberge 21 und in Berlin 19 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenig Wolken. Es bleibt dabei trocken. Vereinzelte Schauer kann es geben in Richtung Flaming und Dosse. Die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 14 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann recht sonnig. Ein paar Wolken sind dabei. Regen soll es aber nicht geben, bei 25 bis 29 Grad. Und die Straßen sind frei.
Gute Fahrt.
Mensch, wenn's in Italien keine Monarchie mehr gibt, dann können wir schnell mal italienische Nationalhymne spielen, oder?
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1?
Dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
So, so weit zu Italien, aber wir sind ja im Chaos Radio Nummer 135. Henrik und Frank vom TTC sind hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir haben eine Telefonnummer, die heißt 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute über die Sicherheit von Karten, auf denen Daten gespeichert werden, die ihr mit euch rumtragt. Also guckt doch mal in euer Portemonnaie oder eure Jackentasche oder wo auch immer ihr eure Kröten versteckt habt, was da so für Karten drin sind. Und wenn ihr euch schon immer gefragt habt, wie funktionieren die Dinge eigentlich und was steht da drauf? Dann haben wir hier die Chance, das zu klären. 0331 70 97 110. Wir hoffen, dass jeder von euch so ein Ding zuhause hat. Die Cash Cow, We are Scientists waren es im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über Karten, die ihr mit euch rumtragt, auf denen Daten gespeichert sind von der EC-Karte oder aber der Geldkarte, über jegliche Karten, auf denen Daten drauf sind. Jan hat ja aus dem Saarland gerade angerufen und gesagt, er hat eine Mensa-Karte und so richtig wohl ist ihm mit dem nicht. Uns angerufen hat der Marco. Hallo Marco, guten Abend.
Also ich habe da eine Frage und zwar zur Sicherheit von EC-Karten beziehungsweise Abhebungen von Geldautomaten. Und zwar gab es da einen Fall und meine Schwiegermutter hatte in 2000 einen Zeitungsladen und ein Kunde von ihr, der hat vom EC-Kartenautomaten, das war Berliner Bank, kurz Busattor hier in Berlin, 300 D-Mark damals noch abgehoben, ist dann zu Karstadt gegangen und hat da was bezahlt. Und einer von den 300ern war falsch, also den hat er aus dem Automat bekommen. Dann hat er sehr viel Ärger bekommen, der ist aber sofort dann zur Berliner Bank gegangen und hat dann also den ganzen Vorgang da erklärt. Und die haben dann irgendwann nach langem Drumherum, weil er auch ein sehr guter Stammkunde von der Berliner Bank ist, dann den 100er gegen einen echten 100er ausgetauscht. Da wollte ich mal fragen, ob das, also die meinen dann auch, also sie können nicht garantieren, dass da echtes Geld aus dem Automaten kommt.
Also es ist zumindest so, dass das Geld, was man reinsteckt, oben reinsteckt, nicht sofort wieder unten. Also es gibt ja heutzutage auch Automaten, die...
Da wollte ich fragen, ob sich da was geändert hat.
Also ne, also es gibt ja heutzutage gibt es auch Automaten, wo man auch Geld einzahlen kann, aber es ist nicht so, dass die dann sozusagen eins zu eins wieder unten landen. Das heißt, das Geld wird immer durch die Bundesbank eigentlich auch geprüft. Das ist schon ein ziemlich guter Check. Also ich glaube, das ist echt so eine von von 10 Millionen Scheinen, wahrscheinlich der es mal dann doch durch schafft oder so.
Und das ist ja in dem Moment eher quasi ein Sicherheitsleck oder ein Problem mit dem Geldschein im Automaten. Das hat jetzt weniger zu tun mit den Karten, über die wir heute reden.
Genau, also man muss halt...
Okay, aber in der Bank kriege ich ja, also da kann ich ja dann, in der Bank kann ich davon ausgehen, dass ich echt das Geld bekomme. Also garantiert kein gefälschtes, aber im Automaten haben die gesagt, können sie es, also da übernehmen sie keine Garantie. Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute auch noch so ist.
Ja, natürlich nehmen sie eine Garantie dafür, klar. Nur hast du natürlich die Arschkarte, das zu beweisen. Also das hast du ja genauso, wenn du aus der Bank rausgehst und kommst dann zehn Minuten später zurück und sagst, ich hab mir einen falschen 100er gegeben, dann werden die auch sagen, schöner Versuch. Aber die gleiche Situation hast du am Geldautomaten auch. Also das Problem ist nur, beim Schalter kannst du halt im Zweifel zwei wirklich nochmal gucken und nochmal echt das Geld checken. Wenn du es rausgehend nicht kriegst, kannst du am Automaten nicht machen. Das ist der Unterschied. Aber ich glaube, das ist und hat eigentlich auch jetzt relativ wenig mit Karten zu tun. Also vielleicht der Hinweis noch, dass also an Geldautomaten auch ziemlich viel protokolliert wird. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon realisiert habt, aber es wird auch in der Regel ein Foto von euch gemacht beim Geld abheben. Mehrere sogar. Da werden in letzter Zeit veröffentlicht, vor allem die Berliner Polizei veröffentlicht auch immer mal wieder Fotos in ihren Polizeiticker irgendwie auf Berlin.de, Polizei.Berlin.de. Und das ist mal ganz spannend zu sehen, was da eigentlich fotografiert wird und in welchen Posen man da, das sieht natürlich ziemlich dämlich aus, wenn man sich da irgendwie rauf stützt, irgendwie diesen Automaten angrinst und wartet, dass sein Geld da endlich rauskommt.
Ist die Kamera hinter der Scheibe oder sind das die normalen Überwachungskameras?
Nee, das sind in der Regel so kleine, ich würde mal sagen, zweimal zwei Zentimeter große Fensterchen. Die können auch ein bisschen versteckt sein. Die sehen so ein bisschen aus wie das Teil, was bei eurer Fernbedienung vom Fernseher, da ist dann so ein Infrarotscheibe, so ein ganz tiefrotes, dunkles Stück ist da. Man sieht es eigentlich fast schwarz aus, wenn man mit einer Taschnapel reinleuchtet.
Dann sieht man auch, dass jemand drin sitzt und dich anguckt.
Genau.
Die andere Frage, die ich noch habe, ist, ich muss öfters Frageld einzahlen. Und das ist mir passiert, ich hab 3000 Euro eingezahlt und dann hat der Automat so komische Geräusche gemacht und dann ist das Geld teilweise verflucht, also so zusammengeknäult und dann hab ich auf Rückgabe gedrückt, dann kam noch ein Teil wieder raus und 50 Euro haben gefehlt. Und dann waren ungefähr so 3 oder 4, 50 Euro scheinbar total zerknickt und so richtig durchgewurschtelt.
Klingt aber auch eher nach einem mechanischen Problem.
Vielleicht hast du ein schlechtes Karma mit der Automaten.
Die haben dann behauptet, es wäre alles okay und so weiter. Und dann später hab ich mit einem von diesen Geldleuten gesprochen, die wechseln diese Automaten und so weiter. Die meinen, dass es öfters vorkommt, dass dann Geld verflucht wird oder so. Aber ich konnte es halt auch nicht beweisen.
Ja, aber das sind alles Sachen, die entweder mit dem Automaten an sich zu tun haben, mit dem Geldschein.
Ja, ich mein, das hat aber mit der Speicherung zu tun. Ich krieg da jetzt praktisch, ich hab keinen Nachweis, wie viel Geld ich pack da in das Geldfach. Und ich krieg dann, ach genau, das wollte ich fragen, dann steht auf dem Beleg öfters, wird geprüft oder erscheinen. Scheinen, ist nicht klar, ob der echt ist und so weiter. Bekomme ich ja so einen Beleg ausgedruckt. Und das hat ja alles mit der EC-Karte zu tun. Das sind alles Vorgänge, die ich mit der EC-Karte mache. Und dann wirft der mir aus, 2900 Euro sind aufs Konto. Um 100 werden auf Echtheit geprüft oder so. Und dann kommt man sich immer vor, als ob man Geldfälscher wäre.
Ja, so was ist... Also in so einer Situation, das hat mir letztens eine Angestellte bei der Bank so erklärt, es kann ein kleiner Haken sein in deinem Geldschein. Er kann ein kleinen Knick sein, der wird geprüft. Aber normalerweise passiert da nichts. Also das sind Momente, da musst du wirklich mal mit deiner Bank reden oder deinem zuständigen Bankberater. Die können dir das auf jeden Fall noch erklären.
Wenn Sie schon mal Geld angeschaut haben, weil ich habe sehr viele mit diesem Geld zu tun, weil ich einzahle, die Scheine sehen sie oft so unterschiedlich. Die sind so unterschiedlich, weil es verschiedene Banken gibt, die die drucken. Früher war es ja nur eine Bank in Deutschland, die die Banken beschrieben hat.
Nee, nee, nee. Also erst einmal Banken drucken das nicht. Genau, eine Firma in Deutschland, die das macht. Und die deutschen Geldscheine sehen auch garantiert alle gleich aus.
Nein. Müssen Sie mal anschauen, die sind verschoben. Also manchmal um einen Zentimeter, um einen halben bis einen Zentimeter verschoben, die Streifen sowohl als auch das Blau ist sehr unterschiedlich. Und es ist total schwierig mittlerweile zu sehen, welcher Schein ist echt oder welcher nicht. Wenn Sie mal 50er müssen Sie mal anschauen.
Marco, pass auf, ich glaube, wir kommen hier nicht wirklich weiter, weil es in dem Fall einfach nicht das Metier ist, wo wir uns jetzt total auskennen. Du solltest da wirklich entweder mit deinem zuständigen Polizeiabschnitt oder einfach wirklich mal mit deiner Bank reden, wenn du da ein Problem hast. Aber das hat zumindest für mein technisches Leihenverständnis nichts mit deiner EC-Karte oder deiner Geldkarte zu tun.
Schauen Sie mal die 50-Euro-Scheine an, die sehen oft verschieden aus. Die Farben und auch die Zahlen sind nicht in den Feldern richtig.
Ich glaube, dass sich in diesem Moment eine Menge Leute das Portemonnaie aufmachen und wenn 50 Euro drin sind, sich diese Scheine angucken.
Dann schauen wir mal ein paar Zehn Stück, garantiert einer anders als anderen, sie werden sich wundern.
Wir gucken mal nach, was da passiert. Danke für den Anruf, Marco. 10 50-Euro-Scheine in einem Portemonnaie, sowas hatte ich ja noch nie.
Die Farben vom 50-Euro-Schein ändern sich auch je nach Blickeinfall.
0331 70 97 1 1 0. Wir reden jetzt nicht explizit über Geld, sondern wir reden über Karten, auf denen ein Magnetstreifen drauf ist oder ein kleiner Chip oder was auch immer. Ein RFID-Chip, über die wir auch noch reden können, auf denen Daten gespeichert werden. Und wenn ihr euch schon mal gefragt habt, was steht da eigentlich? 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Der CTC wird zumindest versuchen, ansatzweise das zu klären. Mit technischen Problemen von Bankautomaten haben wir hier nicht so viel zu schaffen. Aber Murph hat eine Frage zu einem ganz anderen Thema. Und zwar geht es um Chipkarten in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln. Sehr schön. Hallo Murph.
Hallo, ich bin der Murph in 20 Müllers-Bochum. Und es gibt ja diese VDV, also der Ferk 1 zur, weiß nicht, kennt ihr, wisst ihr wie das heißt?
Verkehrsbetriebe.
VDV, genau, Moment. Der Verband deutscher Verkehrsunternehmen hat eine Schnittstelle veröffentlicht, die sogenannte VDV.
VDV Kernapplikation.
Ja, genau. Und da passe ich jetzt ja auch im VHR zum Beispiel die Bugestra drauf an, indem man zum Beispiel jetzt das Ticket 2000 RS-AD-Ship hat und so.
Wir müssen mal ganz kurz für die anderen Hörer, die da jetzt nicht so ganz tief im Thema drinstecken, mal erklären. Also es gibt natürlich schon länger Bestrebungen. In Berlin kennt ihr das, es gab mal so einen Feldversuch Tic-Ed, also Tic-Minus-Ed, wo man so eine Testkarte und die Idee ist einfach bargeldlos zu bezahlen, weil irgendwie Fahrscheinautomaten sind irgendwie nervig, da kommen irgendwie, da stecken Leute Falschgeld rein oder kleben Kaugummi in den Schlitz oder was auch immer.
Der Bus steht zehn Minuten, weil jeder mit einem 5000 Mark Schall kommt.
Genau, man will also irgendwie das Ganze möglichst bargeldlos haben. Das ist natürlich nicht so ganz so ohne, weil in der Regel haben alle Systeme, die bisher irgendwie eingesetzt worden sind, ein ganz gravierendes Datenschutzproblem, weil nämlich in der Regel auch registriert wird, wann wer womit und wohin und wie lange und überhaupt fährt und das ist halt scheiße. Aber trotzdem gibt es immer mal wieder Versuche, so ein System wieder aufzusetzen, sowas zu etablieren und es gab auch schon viele Versuche, das zu vereinheitlichen. Meistens ist es dann aber gescheitert, weil der eine Verkehrsbetrieb hat gesagt, nee, mit der Firma wollen wir aber nicht und das ist blöd und wir hätten die Karten aber lieber gerne rot statt grün und die S-Bahn in Berlin hat gesagt, nee, unsere Bahnsteige, da könnte jetzt keine Automaten, weil die sind gerade gebaut worden und da ist noch Gewährleistung drauf, wenn man da jetzt irgendwie neue Automaten entstellt, dann so Geschichten passieren dann halt und es gibt jetzt eben den Verband der Verkehrsunternehmen, Dingens, VWV und da ist unter anderem, auch wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, die sogenannte Touch and Travel von der Bahn hat auch was damit zu tun. Ich muss mal kurz zu Henrik rüberschauen, der hat sich jetzt glaube ich schon mal ein bisschen näher angeguckt.
Ich hab mir das bloß an, ich weiß im Prinzip, dass das gibt, also sie haben was definiert, was sie VDV Kernapplikationen nennen und was im Prinzip alles ganz toll ist und eierlegende Wollmilchsau und kann man in alle Verkehrsbetriebe integrieren und bisher habe ich davon aber auch nur Bullshit-Bingo gesehen. Also ich hab noch keine ordentlichen Spezifikationen gesehen, vielleicht muss ich einfach bloß besser hingucken.
Naja, die planen ja auch, so zum Beispiel, die planen ja auch in der Zukunft, also eher für die Lesegeräte, dann vorne beim Busfahrer hinzustellen, dass automatisch kontrolliert wird, ob man selbst ein Gült getickert hat. Ich hab da ein paar interessante Unterlagen mal im Netz gefunden, die kann ich euch mal schicken. Na ja, auf jeden Fall, dazu hab ich jetzt mal eine Frage. Und zwar, da ist ja ein RFID-Ship drauf. Den kann man ja auslesen. Und jetzt wollte ich mal fragen, angenommen, die installieren dahinter solche Lesegeräte. Wie kann ich mich dann davor schützen, dass das keiner ausliest? Bezeit hab ich das so gehandhabt, ich hab einfach ne Kopie von dem Ticket, das zeig ich immer vor, das merkt keiner, und das richtige Ticket hab ich in Alufolie vom Zölgut eingewickelt.
Und wenn dann sozusagen dich jemand nach dem richtigen Ticket fragt, ziehst du es aus der Schutzhülle raus?
Ja genau. Und das klappt bisher ganz gut, aber wenn die hinterher eben diese Kartenlesegeräte installieren, wie geh ich dann vor?
Na, zum einen kannst du, also diese Karten sind meistens dual Interface, also du hast ein kontaktloses Interface und ein kontaktbehaftetes daneben, das siehst du an den Kontakten. Das ist dann doof, da musst du wahrscheinlich deine Aluhüllen-Variante weiterführen. Denn zumindest bei den Karten, die ich gesehen habe, wo beide Interfaces sind, habe ich jetzt, ich glaube von sechs Karten, die ich gesehen habe, war bei zwei ein kontaktloses Interface schon einfach so kaputt. So ein kleiner Knick an der Antenne dran und dann war es das. In mindestens einem Fall war das auch völlig unbeabsichtigt.
Und der FöBoot hat ja auch mal gesagt, dass irgendwo, in irgendeiner Stadt mal angeblich so ein Ticket ausgelesen werden soll.
Steht da was drüber? Ja. Wir wollen gerade mal noch nicht zu viel erzählen. Aber es gibt tatsächlich einen Verkehrsverbund, wo, vorsichtig gesagt, ein gravierendes Datenschutzproblem in Zusammenhang mit diesen Tickets besteht. Das heißt also, diese Daten sind irgendwie in keiner Weise irgendwie verschlüsselt und stehen so pikante Sachen drauf, wie bei Schülern ein Name, das Geburtsdatum und die Schule. Und wenn ihr jetzt mal ein bisschen ganz viele fiese Fantasien habt, dann könnt ihr euch da ein echt ekelhaftes Szenario ausdenken. Und wir denken, dass wir da auch entsprechend noch mal darauf aufmerksam machen werden und diese Diskussion um diese RFID-Tickets im Nahverkehr damit dann hoffentlich auch endgültig beenden können, weil das ist eine Technik, die hat da absolut nichts zu suchen. Und eigentlich kann man den Leuten bis dahin nur erraten, eine kleine Ecke abzuschneiden von einem Ticket, dass also diese Antenne zertrennt wird. Man muss sich das bei diesen RFID-Funkchips so vorstellen und diesen Funkkarten. Das ist also wirklich eine Antenne, das ist so eine Schleife, eine kleine Drahtschleife, die geht einmal außenrum um die Karte. Also nicht außenrum, sondern das Innendrin in der Karte drin. Aber es ist eine Antenne, die einmal so den Kreis macht, so groß wie die Karte ist. Am Rand entlang, genau. Das heißt also, wenn ich irgendwie da einen Zentimeter tief oder einen halben Zentimeter tief vorsichtig einschneide, ohne die Karte jetzt ganz kaputt zu machen, dann ist diese Antenne durchtrennt und das Ding kann per Funk nicht mehr ausgelesen werden.
Nur das ist jetzt ja nicht mal ganz so einfach, weil das Ding eben wirklich in der Karte versenkt ist und man kommt da absolut nicht mehr ran. Man müsste höchstens weppen oder so oder Mikrowelle.
Nee, nee, also du kannst schon tatsächlich einfach mit der Schere irgendwie von außen einen Zentimeter irgendwie reinschneiden in die Karte. Das sieht man da klar.
Ja, genau. Mikrowelle würde ich nicht empfehlen. Wir haben da Experimente gemacht. Und wenn man das falsch macht, dann kriegt man tatsächlich über den gesamten Bereich, wo die Antenne ist, also den gesamten Rand lang der Karte einen wunderschönen schwarz verbrannte Karte. Das sieht man dann sehr deutlich.
Dann weiß man aber wenigstens, wo die Antenne ist.
Ja, das sieht man auch viel einfacher, wenn man eine helle Lichtquelle nimmt. Also zum Beispiel aus meinem Handy die Lampe für die Kamera, die funktioniert total prima dafür.
Genau, das ist ein toller Tipp. Also wenn ihr wissen wollt, ob eure Karte möglicherweise funkt oder ob da ein Funkchip drin ist, also direkt funken tun sie ja nicht, sind ja passive Karten, passive Chips, aber wenn ihr wissen wollt, ob da ein Funkchip drin ist, dann könnt ihr diese Karte einfach gegen helles Licht halten und dann seht ihr, dass da irgendwie eine Antenne außen rum geht.
Das hat bisher bei allen Karten funktioniert, die wir in der Hand hatten, bis auf die Bahncard 100, die ist nämlich von beiden Seiten schwarz angemalt.
Das würde ich aber nicht zu lange machen, da hab ich mir schon mal eine Karte durchgeschmort.
Genau, ich hab das mal probiert mit dem Overhead-Projektor, man kann sie ungefähr 3 Sekunden reinhalten, bevor sie weich wird. Wie du sagtest, am besten ist es, einen RFID-Dieselper zu nehmen und keine Mikrowelle, also Starbuck hat Experimente gemacht und meint, wenn man das so ungefähr 3 Sekunden auf niedrigster Leistung hat, dann könnte es funktionieren, das sollte man vielleicht vorher testen und noch ein Glas Wasser da rein tun, das noch die Energie absorbiert. Am besten ist aber wirklich, einen Seper zu bauen. Wir haben da irgendwann mal eine Bauanleitung für gehabt, auf dem Kongress, vor mittlerweile vielen Jahren war das. Da nimmt man sich eine Einwegkamera, macht das Blitzlicht ab, Vorsicht, da ist ein starker Kondensator drin und statt des Blitzlichten eine Antenne ran. Und wenn man das gegen die Karte hält, während man das Blitzlicht zündet, dann ist sie mit relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit kaputt und zwar ohne jegliche von außen sichtbare Beschädigung.
Weitere Haushaltstipps unter ccc.de oder aber 0331 77 97 17 0. Ihr seid im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über Magnetkarten und sonstige Karten, auf denen Daten gespeichert sind. Mörf hatte gerade den sehr netten Einwurf der Chipkarten in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln, was uns ein bisschen von den EC-Karten wegbringt und uns zeigt, es gibt da noch ein Universum außerhalb der Bankkarten, wo man ja als allererstes immer sehr besorgt ist. Mörf, danke für deinen Anruf.
Und zwar diese schöne Sache mit der Paycard, die du angesprochen hast. Das ist natürlich hirnrissig, wenn ein RRVD-Chip drin ist und man da nicht rankommt.
Welche Karte? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ja, diese Karten, die waren ja sowohl als Paycard gedacht, als auch hinterher zum Auslesen. Also als Bush-Ticket praktisch und hinterher noch gleich als Paycard-Funktion.
Meins Geldkarte.
Ja, genau Geldkarte.
Ja, das ist so spezifiziert, es nennt sich dann multifunktionales ZK-Chipkartenbetriebssystem, was man bei ganz viele Sachen machen kann. Und da ist schon seit mehr als zehn Jahren die Funktionalität drin, dass man da auch die Tickets gleich drauf tun kann. Also man kann Geld draufladen und daneben Tickets ablegen. Du meinst nur kontaktlos? So werden die sicherlich auch nicht hergestellt, wenn sie beide Funktionen haben, denn Geldkarte... Geldkarte über kontaktlos ist nicht spezifiziert. Das heißt, wenn eine Geldkarte drin ist, ist auf jeden Fall noch ein Kontaktinterface dran.
0331 70 97 110 von der Verbundkarte der Verkehrsbetriebe kommen wir jetzt zu einem ganz beliebten, wunderbaren Thema von Hannes. Hallo Hannes, guten Abend. Du rufst an von wo?
Nähe Wittstock.
Nähe Wittstock, nördlich von Berlin. Da soll es doch irgendwie viel gewittern heute. Hast du irgendwas gesehen schon?
Noch nicht, also es war ein bisschen dunkel, aber es ist immer so.
Ist bei uns auch, es ist nicht schon normal. Sie nennen es Wetter.
Oder Nacht.
Hannes, du kommst zum beliebten Thema Rabattkarten.
Genau.
Ah, ich liebe es.
Was hast du für einen in der Tasche?
Ne, ich habe, als ich mich da mal kurzzeitig drüber informiert habe, dann doch ganz schnell die Finger vongelassen. Ja, weil man ja damit im Prinzip ja nur den Leuten irgendwie Daten gibt. Aber mich würde vor allen Dingen interessieren, was da einmal drauf ist, inwieweit man auf so eine Sache zugreifen kann, also indem man quasi manipuliert und sagt, ja ich bin gar nicht der und der, sondern ich bin jetzt der und der und habe in Wahrheit schon zehntausendmal Milch gekauft und so.
Und würde jetzt gerne meine Kaffeemaschine als Bonus abholen.
Genau. Für den will ich Kaffee. Ja, es geht darum, ein bisschen Rauschen zu erzeugen und die zu ärgern.
Jo, genau die Idee hatten wir schon mal, beziehungsweise der FöBoot in Bielefeld. Das ist also auch eine so Organisation, die uns sehr nahe steht und sich auch so mit Verbraucherthemen und Datenschutz und Privatsphäre beschäftigt. Die haben ziemlich viel schon über Payback berichtet und Rabattkarten, andere Rabattkarten. Gibt es auch Happy Digital und weiß nicht was alles.
Wie sie alle heißen, die ganzen kleinen hässlichen Dinger.
Und die haben sich mal überlegt, okay, wenn ihr jetzt hier Kundenprofile macht, dann machen wir folgendes. Wir lesen uns mal genau die Geschäftsbedingungen durch für diese Karte. Und da haben sie herausgefunden, dass man die sozusagen die Erstkarte ist quasi personalisiert. Da steht in Geschäftsbedingungen drin, dass also nur der Karteninhaber diese Karte benutzen darf. Aber man kann auch für weitere Personen eine Zweitkarte ausstellen lassen. Prima, lassen wir uns eine Zweitkarte ausstellen. So und da steht ja aber nicht drin, dass man die nur speziell für die eine Person benutzen darf, sondern steht drin und kann sich für weitere Personen eine Zweitkarte ausstellen lassen. Es ging damals um eine Paybackkarte, war eine Magnetstreifenkarte. Wenn man gehört, kann man ganz einfach auslesen, kann man mit einem üblichen Lesegerät auch einfach wieder beschreiben. Und was sie gemacht haben, sie haben Plastikkarten mit Magnetstreifen drauf, haben sie bedrucken lassen, mit einem ähnlich aussehenden Logo, wie das Payback Logo. Nur dass das halt irgendwie nicht die Paybackkarte ist, sondern die Privacy Card. Und was sie gemacht haben, ist einfach die Daten von der Karte, also das ist einfach nur eine Mitgliedernummer. Das ist ja Payback, das ist ja ein Verein, eine Firma. Da ist also einfach tatsächlich nur diese Kartennummer drauf. Das ist irgendwie total unspannend. Das ist also einfach nur eine Datenbanknummer, wo dann intern die Daten gespeichert sind. Haben jedenfalls einfach tausend Stück von diesen Karten hergestellt oder herstellen lassen und haben die verteilt, so jeder, der Bock hatte, irgendwie dem Fibbut irgendwie Payback-Punkte zukommen zu lassen, ist dann beim Einkaufen einfach mit dieser Karte hin, hat die doch vorgelegt, die ist irgendwie piep eingescannt worden und es ist ein wunderbar buntes Kaufprofil entstanden, sogenanntes Rauschen, und der Payback konnte sich dann fürs Büro eine neue Kaffeemaschine. Allerdings hat dann Payback irgendwann von der Sache Spitz bekommen, spätestens dann auch durch die Presse, und dann gab es noch einen längeren Rechtsstreit über die Punkte, die da aufgefallen sind, angefallen sind. Aber die Idee ist tatsächlich, es war ganz lustig, es war ein ziemlich großer Spaß und die Leute haben sich wirklich bemüht, auch die absolut abstrusesten Sachen einkaufen zu gehen und auf jeden Fall war klar, dieses Profil, was da entstanden ist, es war komplett für die Tonne.
Aber steht zum Beispiel, weil die Frage von Hannes ist ja, was steht auf so einer Karte drauf, steht auf dieser Karte, von welcher Firma auch immer, hat gestern 5 Liter Benzin vor, gestern zwei Kaugummis, letzte Woche eine Waschmaschine und vor zwei Wochen ein Düsenjet gekauft.
Also auf der Karte ist tatsächlich einfach nur so eine Kundennummer drauf und die ganzen Verknüpfungen werden dann intern gemacht.
Also es steht nicht drauf, dass du bei der Krankenkasse XY bist und ein Girokonto hast mit einem Dispo von so und so.
Das sind alles Sachen, die denn im System drin stehen.
Das heißt also, wenn man im Prinzip so eine Karte so zuverst generiert, also so eine Kundennummer wird sicherlich nach irgendwelchen Regeln erstellt, irgendwie bauen würde und dann ganz viel, dann würde ja wahnsinnig viel Rausch entstehen. Oder? Also wenn man jetzt so zuverst generierte Kundennummern hat, dann entstehen ja tausende Profile, die überhaupt nichts sagen. Also man tauscht dann meines Wegen die Karten untereinander und...
Ja, aber dann kann es natürlich auch sein, also dann kann man die Karte einfach auch im Müll werfen. Jetzt mal ganz einfach gesagt, also das war halt mal so, als PR-Gag war das ganz lustig, um mal irgendwie auf diese Datensammlung aufmerksam zu machen. Und natürlich auch, was ein großer Spaß war, war dann die gelegentliche Diskussion an der Kasse. So, das ist eine Payback-Karte, irgendwie sieht es komisch aus, weiß ich nicht. So, Friedl, nehmen wir die hier? Ziehen sie mal einfach rüber, ist das schon okay? Dann macht es Piep und alles gut und alle waren glücklich. Es war einfach noch mal eine ganz interessante Bedeutung, dass die Leute dann irgendwie so, es ist eine Karte, ein Privacy-Karte und dann kann man auch ein bisschen da an der Kasse mal ins Gespräch kommen und immer so ein bisschen die Problematik erklären. Und den meisten, ich finde, so die Kastkräften, die da so am Supermarkt sitzen, für die war das natürlich so, boah, wirklich. So, also es war schon mal noch mal ein ganz interessantes Erlebnis.
Also ist bei den Rabattkarten sozusagen das Sicherheitsrisiko nicht ganz so hoch wie jetzt bei einer Bankkarte zum Beispiel?
Ne, überhaupt nicht. Also weil ich glaube, zumindest bei Payback ist es so, dass glaube ich auch so ein Barcode und Strichcode drauf ist, der also alternativ zu den Magnetstreifen ist. Das heißt, da ist einfach die gleiche Nummer drin nur als Barcode. Das heißt also, ich glaube, bei einem Supermarkt, bei mir um die Ecke, da ist es auch so, da wird auch nicht der Magnetstreifen ausgelesen, sondern der Barcode wird rübergezogen, weil es einfach viel, viel schneller geht, als diesen Magnetstreifen auszulesen.
Wenn man diese Magnetstreifen durchzieht, passiert ja immer mal, dass die dann sagen, das Karte ist nicht lesbar, es geht irgendwie nicht. Dann ist entweder der Magnetstreifen oder das Lesegerät kaputt. Ist nicht meine Karte schon manipuliert, muss ich mir Sorgen machen.
Nee, also der Magnetstreifen ist ziemlich anfällig. Also wisst ihr auch, wenn Kassette, wenn die irgendwie zu lange im Auto vorne auf dem Armaturenbrett gelegen haben, in der Sonne.
Das waren die, wo man auf der A und B Seite MP3s drauf hat, die Kassetten. Hannes, ich hoffe, die Frage ist beantwortet damit. Als letzte Amtshandlung kannst du noch sagen, wie spät es ist.
Du, ich bin Schüler, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie spät es ist.
Du wirst eine Uhr in deiner Nähe haben. Komm, geh mal gucken. Du musst irgendwoher wissen, wie spät es ist. Wenn du Schüler bist, musst du ja morgen pünktlich aufstehen.
11 Uhr sagt mein Bruder gerade.
Danke schön. Chaos Radio Nummer 135, hier mit dem Chaos Computer Club Henrik Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit unter 0331 70 97 110 miteinander zu reden. Es geht heute um Karten, die auf denen ein Magnetstreifen oder irgendeine Form von Datenspeicher Medium drauf ist, wo ihr euch vielleicht schon mal gefragt habt, was steht da eigentlich drin? Und wenn ich diese Karte verliere, was weiß derjenige über mich, der das Ding auslesen kann? Soweit können wir klären. Wir hatten schon die Karte in der Mensa. Wir haben natürlich über Geldautomaten geredet. Mörf hat angesprochen, die Karten, die RFID-Chips, die im Nahverkehr eingesetzt werden bei der Bahn und in Bussen. Und eben gerade noch der Einwand von Hannes. Wie ist das eigentlich mit Rabattkarten? Wenn ihr eine Frage habt, einfach durchklingeln. 0331 70 97 110. She took all the money, Francis Black war das im Chaosradio auf Fritz03317097110. Alex hat uns angerufen. Hallo Alex. Ja hallo.
Von wo rufst du an?
Ich ruf aus Berlin an.
Aus Berlin, aus Berlin, ne, den will ich jetzt nicht machen. Du hast eine Frage zum Thema PIN auf der Bankkarte.
Ja, Frage-Feststellung. Es wird vorhin gesagt worden, die PIN wäre auf den modernen Bankkarten, nicht mehr drauf, oder mal Jespro-Karten. Hat sich denn beim CCC jemand mal Gedanken gemacht, wie das Verfahren Chip-Offline funktioniert?
Ja, also es ist nicht mehr ein Magnetstreifen drauf, das war denke ich gemeint.
Ach, das war gemeint, genau. Aber das bedeutet doch, die PIN ist ja letztendlich auf dem Chip oder im Chip gespeichert.
Ja, aber nicht unbedingt als PIN. Also zum einen hast du das Problem, dass der Chip dir nicht erlaubt ist, auszulesen, was drauf gespeichert ist, sondern du musst da dann anfangen, irgendwie mit Säuren und Mini-Nadeln und so weitererrum zu stochern, um überhaupt was auslesen zu können. Und dann ist in der Regel nicht die PIN gespeichert, sondern so eine Art Prüf-Simulator drauf. Also in dem einen Verfahren verschlüsselt man die PIN mit sich selber zum Beispiel. Oder die PIN wird mit einem kartenspezifischen Schlüssel verschlüsselt, der aber nicht auf der Karte gespeichert ist zum Beispiel.
So, der Matheleistungskurs hat zwei Stunden Zeit, um zu erklären und das mal darzulegen und dann an der Tafel auszurechnen.
Also es bedeutet, dass wenn einem jetzt eine Karte mit Chip in die Hände fällt, man eigentlich keine Möglichkeit hat, die PIN so auszulesen, dass man die Karte trotzdem verwenden kann.
So ist es im Prinzip gedacht.
Also vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Einwurf dazu. Es gab ja diese Sendung gestern Abend, wo auch so ein bisschen der Eindruck erweckt wurde, dass das aktuelle Sicherheitsproblem, was mit dem Chip zu tun haben könnte, da will ich vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen, dass viele Fälle, die für die Recherche da vorgelegen haben, die also gar keinen Chip drauf hatten. Es ist also kein Problem, dass grundsätzlich dieser Chip irgendwie einen Anzeichen oder die Chance erhöhen könnte, dass da jetzt ein Sicherheitsproblem ist, dass jemand diese PIN erraten könnte. Bei den Fällen, die wir jetzt kennen, ist da kein Zusammenhang herzustellen.
Ja, also gut, jetzt wollte ich mir nochmal noch einmal nachraten mit der PIN auf dem Chip, weil das vorhin so ein bisschen unklar war, dass die PIN halt nicht auf der Karte überhaupt drauf wäre.
Wobei, also vielleicht nochmal, so gut, dass du es auch nochmal anbringst, es gibt auch zwei unterschiedliche Verfahren bei dem EC oder bei diesem Offline-Prüfung, bei diesem EC-Karten mit Chip. Da ist eins, das sogenannte passive Verfahren, das ist auch vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren ging das mal durch die Medien. Da haben Leute auch geschafft, die Kommunikation zwischen Lesegerät und Chip mitzuschneiden und da auch die Authentifizierung des Gerätes, die eigentlich gemacht werden sollte, wieder sozusagen aufzunehmen und wieder einzuspielen und damit ein falsches Lesegerät vortäuschen und so Geschichten. Das sind Chips, die aber eigentlich theoretisch nicht im Einsatz sein sollten, die aber von einigen Banken doch aus Kostengründen verwendet worden sind. Ob das Ganze jetzt praxisrelevant ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen, weil der Aufwand ist schon relativ groß, das zu machen. Und wahrscheinlich sind also diese 90% klassischen Skimming-Fälle, wo also der Magnetstreifen abgefischt wird und die Pin irgendwie abgefilmt wird beim Eingeben, sind da wahrscheinlich eher ein größeres Problem. Und zwar noch irgendwas wollte ich noch zu pinnen offline. Ja gut, die Banken stellen übrigens deswegen nicht um. Das ist deren Argumentation. Die könnten ja sagen, okay, jetzt 30 Jahre Magnetstreifen ist genug. Wir stellen jetzt auf Chip um, weil das ist sicherer, weil das ist so, dass das Lesegerät sich auch, also das Gerät, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo einkaufen gehe und da meine Schuhe irgendwo im Laden bezahlen will mit EC-Karte, dann stecke ich in so ein sogenanntes POS, Point of Sale Terminal rein. Und die Dinger sind eigentlich schon ziemlich sicher, die in Deutschland stehen. Andererseits weiß ich natürlich als Kunde gar nicht, ob das Gerät auch wirklich ein POS-Terminal ist oder irgendwie nicht nur ein umlackierter Taschenrechner, wo ich dann irgendwie meine PIN-Eintippe-Karte reingestecke und zack, Daten sind weg. Das sind Fälle, die gibt es auch zu Tausenden, passieren die. Das ist ein ganz großes Missbrauchsproblem. Und deswegen könnte man sagen, okay, Chip darf also nur die Sachen, darf überhaupt nur mit dem Lesegerät sprechen, wenn sich das Lesegerät ordentlich bei dem Chip identifiziert als ein echtes Lesegerät. Da ist irgendwie auch so ein Hochsicherheitsmodul drin. Das ist auch echtes, ordentliches Stück Technik, was sich ja sofort selbst zerstört, wenn man das irgendwie anbohrt und so Geschichten. Da sind also dann diese geheimen Schlüssel drin, um mit der Karte zu kommunizieren. Also alles ziemlich komplex, aber an sich ist die Chip-Geschichte schon ganz gut. Aber es ist natürlich wahnsinnig aufwendig. Wenn man sagt, wir wollen jetzt vom Magnetstreifen weg und wollen weltweit alle Geräte umstellen, ist das natürlich ein riesen Batzen Geld, den die Banken da investieren müssen. Und das müsste eigentlich auf einen Schlag passieren oder möglichst auf einen Schlag. Und bisher konnten sich die Banken da noch nicht auf ein ordentliches Umstiegsszenario einigen. Und es ist nicht so, dass es ein Problem nur in Deutschland ist mit dem Magnetstreifen, sondern es ist weltweit ein Problem. Aber offensichtlich scheint der Leidensdruck noch nicht groß genug zu sein, weil die Gerichte, wenn dann Missbrauch passiert, leider immer noch für die Banken und gegen den Kunden entscheiden würden. Wenn jetzt die Gerichte sagen würden, ey Banken jetzt 30 Jahre Magnetstreifen, Schluss jetzt, Feierabend, macht Chip, und ihr müsst jetzt dem Kunden Geld erstatten, dann würden die Banken sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schneller überlegen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein deutsches Problem. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal guckt in Frankreich oder Großbritannien, werden der Kreditkarten grundsätzlich noch mit Chip ausgegeben. In Frankreich ist es zum Beispiel so, dass man sogar bei der Kreditkarte, bei einer inländischen, französischen Karte den PIN eingeben muss, um mit der Karte zu bezahlen. Also ich hab auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es auch so ein bisschen daran liegt, dass die Deutschen sich das so ein bisschen gemütlich gemacht haben.
Ja total, auf jeden Fall. Also die sagen halt immer, naja, wir müssen die deutschen Karten, die müssen ja auch irgendwie Magnetstreifen haben, weil die Leute wollen ja auch im Ausland. Aber dann könnte man sagen, okay, wenn ich als normaler Bürger irgendwie, ich brauch nicht ins Ausland, ich bin halt in Deutschland und ich will einfach für Deutschland eine sichere Karte haben, dann wäre das auch durchaus machbar. Wenn ich sag, okay, ich will jetzt im Ausland auch, dann hol ich meine extra Karte, wo ein Magnetstreifen ist. Da gelten dann irgendwie, die kann dann auch nicht in Deutschland benutzt werden und so Geschichten. Das wäre ja schon alles denkbar. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen mehr Aufwand, kostet ein bisschen mehr Geld, aber offensichtlich scheint der Leidensdruck bei den Banken noch nicht groß genug zu sein.
EC-Karte, weil Sie gesagt haben, also Dinge heißen ja inzwischen Magestro-Karte, nicht mehr EC-Karte.
Ja, aber unter uns ist das quasi dasselbe, oder?
Ja, genau, ja klar. Aber die Dinge heißen halt. Aber was ich Ihnen sagen wollte, der Tipp ist eigentlich der, weil vorhin gesagt worden ist, man könnte die nicht ohne PIN bestellen. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also ich weiß zumindest von den ost- und norddeutschen Sparkassen, die am selben Rechenzentrum dranhängen, dass sie dort technisch die Möglichkeit haben, die Karte ohne PIN zu bestellen. Das Problem ist nur, dass die meisten Leute, also die meisten Berater in den Filialen nicht wissen, dass es geht. Aber es geht.
Ich glaube, wir waren nicht bei den Maestro-Karten, sondern wir waren bei Kreditkarten.
Genau, aber das ist ein Punkt. Man kann das natürlich auch machen. Man kann sagen, zur Bank gehen, hier ist der Briefumschlag irgendwie. Bitte bestätigen Sie mir, dass Sie den unversehrt empfangen haben. Und dann bin ich natürlich auch raus aus der Sache.
Gut, Alex, danke dir. Alles klar, gerne. Schönen Abend, tschüss. Mir fällt jetzt siebenteils ein, dass es 10 nach 11 ist und wir haben noch nicht ein einziges Mal deinen mit unglaublich technischem Aufwand hergestellten Sound des Kartenlesegerätes gehört. Also bitte, lauschen Sie jetzt. Der nächste am Telefon ist Mike. Hallo Mike.
Hallo.
Grüß dich, was ist deine Frage?
Ich hab Probleme mit meiner IC-Karte. Und zwar, also wird die nicht richtig ausgelesen. Also ich hab das jetzt eh mal erlebt bei so einem Druckgerät. Da hat der die nicht gelesen. Und dann bin ich zu so einem Automaten, Bankautomaten, gesagt.
Du meinst so einem Kontoausdrucksdrucker.
Dann bin ich zu so einem Automaten gegangen, also der Bargeld aussehen hat. Der hat die wieder gelesen. Und da war heute so ein mobiler Lieferdienst. Und der wollte meine EC-Karte auch lesen. Und da hat er die wieder nicht auslesen können.
Da musst du einfach mal zur Bank gehen. Hast du dich vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen draufgesetzt oder mal ein bisschen nah an die große Lautsprecherbox gekommen bei der Party oder so?
Bei Bezahlen annehmen?
Also äußerlich ist das alles...
Ne, Magnetstreifen siehst du nicht. Siehst du ja bei einer Kassette auch nicht, ob da was drauf ist oder nicht.
Also zur Bank gehen und dann nochmal umtauschen.
Kriegst du eine neue.
Und was muss man eigentlich genau achten? Was darf nicht passieren? Also nehmen...
Alles was stärker Magnetfelder erzeugen.
Radio, also...
Meistens nicht, aber Lautsprecherboxen kommen große...
Fernseher, also Röhrenfernseher auch nicht drauflegen.
Alte Fernseher im Kaufhaus, die Diebstahlsicherungsabmachgeräte.
Das hat schon einen Grund, da steht immer hier keine Kreditkarten und EC-Karten drauflegen. Das ist schon ernst gemeint, das solltet ihr nicht tun.
Sonst machst du plupp und da ist nix mehr drauf.
Genau.
So wie wahrscheinlich bei dir jetzt passiert. Bist du irgendwo an den Magneten vorbeigelaufen?
Oder die hat mal in der Sonne gelegen, was auch immer.
0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über Plastikkarten, auf denen Daten gespeichert werden. Wenn ihr mal wissen wolltet, was steht da eigentlich drauf, ruft uns an. Der nächste ist Tom. Hallo. Hallo. Von wo rufst du an?
Aus Berlin-Rundchenhausen.
Aus Rundchenhausen.
Und meine Frage ist, ich hatte mal vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Fernsehbericht gesehen. Da hatten sie Berichte über manipulierte Lesegeräte in Tankstellen, Supermärkten und so weiter. Wo dann praktisch, während man seinen Einkauf bezahlt hat, dass alles mitgelesen wurde und dann per E-Mail an irgendwelche Adressen im Ausland verschickt wurden und dann, was vorhin schon gesagt wurde, im Ausland mit solchen Rohlingen dann halt abgehoben wurde. Kann man sich da irgendwie verschützen?
Nee, kannst du nicht. Das ist auch noch ein Grund mehr, warum dieser Magnetstreifen endlich sterben muss, ist das Thema. Weil du einfach als Kundin nicht weißt, wo du deine Karte reinsteckst und wo du deine PIN eingibst. Also kann einfach auch sein, dass ein Geldautomat, da gab es auch schon Fälle, dass die Leute einfach einen komplett falschen Geldautomat hingestellt haben. Dann kamen halt irgendwie raus, wenn wir 50 Euro, sorry, mehr haben wir gerade nicht oder so. Und eine Minute später wurden dann 1000 Euro von einem Konto abgehoben. Also du kannst einfach nichts trauen, keinem Geräten trauen, wo du deine Karte reinsteckst. Das ist natürlich ein großes Dilemma. Natürlich macht man sich das auch. Aber es gibt keinerlei Möglichkeiten festzustellen, was da in diesem Gerät passiert mit deinen Daten.
Also dann jetzt nur noch mit Unterschrift bezahlen.
Das wäre eigentlich der sichere Weg, ja.
Aber nur mit Papierunterschrift, nicht mit solchen Unterschriftenpads.
Wobei da glaube ich die Beweiskraft auch nur so Mittel ist.
Der Nachteil ist vor allen Dingen, dass wenn sie das richtig aufzeichnen, sodass du den Winkel und den Andpressdruck des Stifts speicherst, dann kann im Prinzip jemand, der die Daten speichert, anschließend sich hinsetzen und basierend auf diesen Daten versuchen genau den gleichen Winkel und Andpressdruck nachzumachen und kann anschließend eine Papierunterschrift perfekt nachmachen, wo dann auch kein Experte mehr bezeugen kann, dass es nicht deine Unterschrift war.
Richtig. Wobei andererseits die Unterschriften, ich glaube die werden nicht, es gibt kein System, die die prüfen, oder? Also in der Regel kann man da mit drei Kreuzen unterschreiben.
Prüft werden sie nicht, aber es gab wohl mal Bestrebungen, das als biometrisches Merkmal einzuführen.
Also wie du persönlich den Stift hältst, welche Schrift.
Genau.
Wobei es gibt ja mittlerweile in Deutschland schon mehrere große Ketten, bei denen man, wenn du eine EC-Zahlung hast, also eine bargeldlose Zahlung, schon das von Hendrik angesprochene Terminal hast, wo du so ein Bildschirm hast, auf dem man dann unterschreiben muss, wo du nicht mehr auf dem Papier unterschreibst.
Kannst du mit Mickey Maus unterschreiben.
Und dann sagt dir, ne ne, dann sagt dir das Ding, die Unterschrift stimmt nicht, bitte machen sie es nochmal. Ne.
Aber wenn es jemand hat oder nochmal erklären kann, also sagt mir, wo so ein Ding steht, ich probier's aus, aber ich kann nicht.
Bei Parkstationen hab ich schon probiert, das heißt, bitte unterschreiben sie mit dem Finger auf dem Bildschirm, da hab ich schon mal kleine Bildchen gemalt. So ein Häuschen und eine Sonne, aber... Ich mein, wenn das Ding mich auffordert, auf dem Bildschirm zu malen.
Also diese Unterschriftprüfung, die funktioniert... Ihr kennt das ja auch, wenn ihr ein Paket bekommt von DHL oder UPS oder sowas, die halten euch so ein Ding hin, und da machst du halt irgendwie was auch immer, es kann eh kein Mensch lesen und auch nichts vergleichen oder so. Das ist eher so eine pro forma Geschichte. Aber beim Bezahlen... Glaube ich nicht. Also das... Guck mal kurz Henrik hier an. Also wie gesagt, würde mich sehr wundern, wenn...
Nehmt das mal als nächstes Projekt auf. Wir probieren das mal aus und halten euch da auf dem Laufenden. Warte mal, jetzt haben wir Johannes am Telefon. Hallo Johannes. Nee, wobei. Christian wartet länger. Johannes, bleib geduldig. Ich bin ja ein fairer Mensch. Hallo Christian.
Hallo.
Du rufst an aus Berlin.
Ja.
Sag mir deine Vorwahl.
Genau.
Mehr weiß ich über dich aber nicht, deswegen musst du deine Frage stellen.
Ja, also ich hab auch eine Mensakarte. Und zwar vom Studentenwerk Berlin, irgend so ein Ding. Und also erstmal hat mich interessiert, als eingeführt wurde, dass man nur noch mit dieser Mensakarte sich sein Essen kaufen darf. Ja, was da drauf gespeichert wird. Oder ob, da ist halt ein Geldbetrag drauf. Ob der im System gespeichert wird oder auf der Karte. Oder was...
Ob die Karte speichert, dass du kein Spinat essen magst.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Und ich hab's einfach nicht rausgekriegt. Also ich hab mehrere E-Mails an Studentenwerk geschrieben und hab da auf den Seiten und so geguckt, aber ich hab nichts rausgekriegt. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was da, wo gespeichert wird.
Entschuldigung, hab ich grad nicht mitgekriegt. Kontaktlos?
Ja, Kontaktlos.
Dann ist das mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit MyFair Classic. Das setzen im Wesentlichen alle deutschen Universitäten ein, die solche Karten einführen. Also ist alles sehr beliebt. Und das sind Verfahren, wie ich schon erwähnte, was auf Security bei Obscurity basierte. Wir haben das Verschlüsselungsverfahren vor einiger Zeit reverse-ingeniert durch reingucken in die Karten. Das Verschlüsselungsverfahren ist bekannt. Und in absehbarer Zeit werden wir auch vorführen können, dass man einfach Karten lesen kann. Und bei diesen Karten, die sind extra entwickelt worden als solche Geldbörsenkarten für genau diese Anwendung in Mensen zum Beispiel. Die haben also eine spezielle Funktion. Also sie haben mehrere Sektoren, haben eine spezielle Funktion, dass du einen Block in so einem Sektor als Börse definieren kannst. Also dass da ein Geldbetrag drauf ist. Der wird dann direkt drauf gespeichert. Und du kannst dann definieren, dass das Erhöhung des Betrags und das Enhiedrigen des Betrags unterschiedlich gehandhabt werden. Mit verschiedenen Schlüsseln zum Beispiel. Aber was sie im Wesentlichen bei allen diesen Systemen noch zusätzlich dazu haben, dass sie den Geldbetrag auf der Karte speichern, ist ein Schattenkonto im Hintergrund. Um dann zum Beispiel, wenn du die Karte verloren hast, dir den Betrag wieder herstellen zu können. Also bei uns hier in Berlin ist es so, dass du da richtig Informationsblättchen dazu kriegst, dass du dir die Nummer, die auf der Karte draufstehst, irgendwo noch notieren sollst, sodass, wenn du die Karte verlierst, gehst du mit der Nummer einfach zum Studentenwerk. Sie überweisen dir den Betrag entweder auf eine neue Karte oder geben ihn dir so oder was auch immer und sperren deine alte Karte.
Oh, was ist da mit dem Informationsblättchen, was Henry gerade erwähnt hat?
Da, als es eingeführt wurde, lagen überall Blättchen raus und das wissen die auch an den Kassen alle. Und es hängen auch, sie haben relativ viel Werbung dazu gemacht und es steht auch alles auf der Webseite drauf.
Also wo war das? An welcher Uni?
Hier Berlin Studentenwerk, also alle Uni.
Ach so, aber ja okay, bei mir an der Uni...
Welche Uni ist denn das?
An der TfH, also Technische Fachhochschule. Da habe ich so ein Infoblatt nie gefunden. Ich wurde nur irgendwann mal unfreundlich darauf hingewiesen, hier geht jetzt nicht mehr mit Bargeld. Und dann musste ich halt mir irgendwie für 1, 60 Euro so eine Karte ausstellen lassen.
Oh, sie haben es erhöht. Es waren mal 1, 55 Euro.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht mehr. Vielleicht waren es auch 1, 55 Euro. Und musste da halt irgendeinen Betrag drauf zahlen.
Na Krissan, das ist doch die beste Möglichkeit, mal deinen lokalen Studentenwerkvertreter anzurufen und zu sagen, Kollege, wir haben keine Informationsblättchen, kümmer dich mal.
Genau. Also es steht auf der Webseite, aber eigentlich sollten auch über Informationen ausliegen, oder sie haben Plakate aufgehängt mit der Werbung für das neue System. Die sind lila.
Ja, so wie die Karte wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht hört ja auch jemand vom Studentenwerk Berlin zu, hat dieses Manko erkannt und wird sich darum kümmern, dass diese Lücke sofort abgestellt wird. Die TfH in Berlin hat keine Informationen über die Geldkarte, die an die Studenten ausgegeben werden, vielleicht könnt ihr das bitte ändern. Vielen Dank.
Ja, also dazu, also zu der Karte muss ich noch sagen, ich finde es irgendwie extrem unpraktisch. Also vielleicht spart man damit an der Kasse ein paar Sekunden, weil man nicht nach seinem Kleingeld suchen muss. Aber irgendwie ist es blöde, wenn ich, also ich kann die Karte ja nur da benutzen und ich habe immer auch Geld in der Tasche, weil ich muss ja zwischendurch auch irgendwo anders Sachen einkaufen. Und wenn ich jetzt auf dieser Karte irgendwie nur noch 50 Cent drauf habe und mir aber einen Kakao für 80 Cent kaufen will und jetzt noch 40 Cent in der Tasche habe, dann funktioniert das nicht, weil diese Automaten, wo ich die Karte aufladen kann, die nehmen nur 50 Cent Stücke als kleines Geld.
Ja, ja, diese Karten sind sehr unpraktisch. Das haben wir auch festgestellt. Also früher ging es zumindest bei uns in Atlas Hof an der Universität noch so, dass du an den Karten mit Geld oder mit Karte, und wenn du nicht genau auf der Karte drauf hattest, haben sie es dir schnell auf die Karte draufgebucht. Das haben sie dann aber zum Anfang dieses oder des letzten Semesters auch abgeschafft. Zum Beispiel, ich lade immer 5 Euro auf meine Karte auf. Ich habe aber nur einen 10-Euro-Schein. Das Verfahren ist dann so, dass ich zur Kasse gehe, sage, ich möchte gerne 5 Euro aufladen. Dann sagen sie mir, nee, ich kann hier nicht aufladen, sondern geben mir für meinen 10-Euro-Schein zwei Fünfer. Mit einem der Fünfer gehe ich dann zum Automaten zurück, lade den Fünfer auf die Karte auf und gehe dann zur Kasse zurück, bezahle, was ich bezahlen wollte.
Ach, deswegen dauert Studieren so lange. Danke, Christian.
Ja, ich wollte dazu noch eine Frage stellen. Irgendwie beunruhigt mich bisher schon, dass ich halt den Betrag von der Karte abgebucht kriege, ohne dass ich irgendwo okay sage. Also die Frauen an der Kasse sagen immer recht unfreundlich, so jetzt Karte rauflegen hier und ich war noch nicht mal, also ich hab's noch nicht mal geschafft zu identifizieren, wo da jetzt auf dem Display der Betrag steht, der jetzt abgebucht wird.
Direkt beim Kartenauflegen. Ja. Ja, das Kartenterminal hat so ein kleines Display drin. Ja, genau.
Aber ich brauch halt immer irgendwie eine Sekunde, um zu sehen, welcher Betrag jetzt da steht. Und ich möchte halt sehen, was ich bezahle, wenn ich bezahle.
Na, das kannst du gleich reklamieren. Also das ist mir auch schon ein paar Mal passiert, dass irgendwie eine neue Kassiererin hat das falsch eingegeben. Wenn du es dann sofort sagst, die können tatsächlich noch Geld zurückbuchen.
Nein, also mir geht es einfach darum, dass ich eine Sekunde brauche. Ich werde aber von denen oft angeflaumt, dass ich halt zu langsam reagiere.
Na ja, da kann aber deine Karte ja in dem Fall nicht dafür. Das ist ja eher ein Kommunikationsproblem zwischen dir und deiner Kassiererin.
Die Mentalität, die dahinter steckt, stört mich ein bisschen. Also eigentlich wollen die von mir, dass ich sofort, wenn ich an die Kasse komme, meine Karte da auf dieses Lesegerät drauflege und die einfach den Betrag abbuchen können. Und das ganze Verfahren geht so schnell, also dass ich eine Sekunde Zeit habe, um zu checken, welcher Betrag wurde denn jetzt abgebucht. Okay, ich kann hinterher zum Lesegerät gehen.
Da waren bestimmt Roland Berger oder so ein Kandidat am Spiel, die gesagt haben, das kriegen wir noch drei Sekunden kürzer hin.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, ohne Authentisierung ist oder ohne irgendwelche Bestätigung des Karteninhabers ist bei diesen Karten tatsächlich sehr böse, denn man kann zum Beispiel so eine Art Wurmloch bauen. Also man baut eine Kartenfälschung, etwas, was so tut, als wäre es eine Karte und ein Lesegerät, verbindet die miteinander entweder über ein längeres Kabel oder über eine Funkverbindung und hat dann zwei Leute. Einer stellt sich an die Kasse bezahlt mit der falschen Karte und einer stellt sich mit dem falschen Lesegerät neben einer echten Karte, zum Beispiel neben deiner, weil er hinter dir in der Schlange steht. Und die Karte wird dann quasi, die falsche Karte tut dann so, als wäre es deine. Auch wenn sie nichts über deine Karte weiß, sie leitet einfach alles, was das Echte Lesegerät mit der falschen Karte sagt, leitet das falsche Lesegerät an die echte Karte weiter und die Antworten wieder zurück.
Dosentelefon 2.0.
Genau, das nennt man dann einfach Wurmloch, zum Beispiel nach dieser Analogie. Und damit kannst du dann im Prinzip bei allen kontaktlosen Karten, alle kontaktlosen Karten haben genau dieses Problem, vor allen Dingen, wenn sie halt die Abbuchung machen, ohne dass du noch mit PIN eingeben musst oder so. Dass du im Prinzip, wenn jemand sich an dich ranschleichen kann und dein falsches Lesegerät an dich ranhalten kann, wenn du zumindest solange wie in deiner Nähe ist, mit der Karte bezahlen.
Also er kann praktisch, wenn er vor mir in der Schlange steht, praktisch mit meiner Karte bezahlen, weil er die sozusagen verlängert mit dem Lesegerät, mit dem Lesegerät.
Christian, sei wachsam, weil wir haben jetzt noch ein paar Leute. Sei wachsam, deine Frage, pass auf deine Frage.
Für einen Bestätigungsknopf auf den Ding an, der erst die Antenne aktiviert.
Genau, das ist eine ganz, ganz großartige Idee. Bei RFID, das unterstützen wir auch voll und ganz, wäre eigentlich auch technisch nicht so aufwendig. Das würde diese ganzen Privatsphäre-Geschichten wahnsinnig erleichtern, wenn man einfach so einen kleinen Taster hätte auf der Karte, jetzt darfst du funken.
Mal gucken, ob du voll bist. Christian, bleib wachsam, sei lieb zu den Frauen in der Kantine. Der nächste am Telefon ist Johannes. Hallo Johannes.
Grüß dich. Ich wollte ja eigentlich ursprünglich was zu dem Thema Führerscheine sagen, aber weil ihr jetzt gerade bei dem Thema Studentenkarten seid, von dem Studentenwerken, das nenne ich gerade, ich habe es heute im Internet gelesen, und zwar ich studiere in Magdeburg an der Uni, und da ist ein Datensecker irgendwie passiert, da haben die diese gesamten Daten von den Studenten, also jetzt die gesamten Stammdaten und sowas, haben die online gestellt auf irgendeinen Server, und die waren halt öffentlich in...
Zwei Wochen lang.
Zwei Wochen lang, genau, die waren öffentlich zugänglich. Und dabei zählt mir nämlich gerade auf, dass auf unserem Studentenausweis ist es ja so, dass ich mit diesem Studentenausweis sowohl in die Bibliothek gehen kann, als auch nicht über online einloggen kann, über diese Nummer, die ich da drin habe, bzw. auch, im Grunde meine gesamten Daten, die ich in der Universität da irgendwo gespeichert habe, da unendbar. Aber da darf nur so ganz nebenbei. Aber eigentlich wollte ich ja auch auf den Führerschein hinaus, und zwar ist es, meine Frage ist nämlich, wenn ich meinen Führerschein habe, da ist ja auch irgendwie, dann muss ja mein Alter auf dem Führerschein irgendwie gespeichert sein, bzw. auch mein, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob da meine Namen und meine gesamten Stammdaten gespeichert sind, wenn ich die dann in diesen Zigarettenautomat mal reinstecke, um mir dann Zigaretten zu kaufen, wird es dann gespeichert oder wie funktioniert das dann?
Auf jeden Fall machen Sie einen Vermerk in deinen Führerschein, dass Rauchen ungesund ist.
Der Führerschein ist gar nicht elektronisch, ne?
Nee, der Führerschein ist nicht elektronisch. Da ist unten die Maschinenlesbare Zone drauf zurzeit.
Genau, Maschinenlesbare Zone kennt ihr auch vom Personalausweis. Das sind so zwei Zeilen, mehr oder weniger kryptische, ne, eigentlich nicht kryptische, sondern lesbare Zeichen, aber sehen halt so ein bisschen in einer besonderen Schrift. Das ist eine sehr einfache, ja, Maschinenlesbare, deswegen heißt die Maschinen- readable Zone Maschinenlesbare Zone. Ist auch wichtig bei den neuen Reisepässen. Das ist ein, da wird ein spezieller Code raus erzeugt, mit dem man dann mit dem Chip sprechen kann, also das Lesegerät dann mit dem Chip sprechen kann. Und bei den Zigarettenautomaten ist es so, wir haben da vorher noch schonmal drüber gesprochen, hier bei uns intern, wir sind ja alle nicht Raucher, deswegen war da nicht so Firmen drin. Aber man kann, glaube ich, auch einen Personalausweis da reinstecken, der wird dann irgendwie auch eingelesen. Bei manchen Geräten, ja.
Ja, da ist halt größer, deswegen geht das nicht bei allen.
Genau, und da ist dann quasi wie so ein kleiner Scanner drin, der irgendwie die Schrift einscannt, die da drauf ist. Und dann gibt es irgendwie so, kann man auch so ein Prüf-Summenverfahren machen, wo man also quasi Quersumme, Prüf-Summe erzeugt. Da gibt es übrigens, möchte ich mal drauf hinweisen, es gibt eine ganz gute Webseite für, wo das Ganze gesammelt ist, die heißt www.prüfziffernberechnung.de. Da habe ich auch noch gerade etwas über Payback gefunden. Könnte aber auch selbst klicken, wollte ich gerade noch kurz noch erwähnen, weil die Frage vorher aufkam bei Payback. Da ist es genau erklärt, was auf der Karte drauf ist. Also da ist irgendwie so eine Kennung für den Laden, quasi wo man die bekommen hat, wer einen geworben hat. Und eine Kundennummer und auch so ein Prüfziffer, mehr ist da nicht drauf. Das gibt es bei Prüfziffernberechnung, die haben dann eine ganz gute Sammlung von diesen ganzen Sachen. Und das ist eigentlich auch oftmals die erste Anlaufstelle, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie einen obskuren Code habe irgendwo und ich will wissen, was steht da eigentlich drin. Also zum Beispiel Reisepass, was ist da in diesen Zeilen und kodiert.
Aber jetzt zurück zur Frage von Johannes. Speichert der Zigarettenautomat jetzt, dass Johannes bei Ihnen Zigaretten gekauft hat, und zwar an dem und dem Tag. Und außerdem seit so und so lange seinen Führerschein hat.
Können tut sie das natürlich. Ich glaube, wir müssen einfach mal darauf vertrauen, dass sie das nicht tun.
Oder dass es ihnen zu aufwendig ist, das zu tun, weil da muss man dann Speicher rein tun, muss den auslesen, auswerten und so weiter. Sie haben selber schon genug damit zu tun, Zigaretten zu verkaufen.
Na, es hätte ja sein können, dass sie das dann speichern. Und dann irgendwie, was weiß ich nicht, in 20 Jahren bin ich dann mal, wenn ich vielleicht noch irgendeine Krankheit habe, dass dann von der Krankenkasse gesagt wird, ja, sie rauchen ja aber schon seit dem und dem Zeitpunkt. Und sie haben ja in dem und dem Zeitpunkt Zigaretten gekauft. Und deswegen, weiß ich ja nicht.
Ja, im Zweifelsfall, wenn du Zigaretten kaufst, Ich hab die mal für meinen kleinen Bruder geholt. Ja, für irgendjemand mitbringst, ist ja was anderes. Aber solltest du in 20 Jahren krank werden, weil du geraucht hast, dann wird dein Arzt auch sehen, dass du seit 20 Jahren rauchst. Das Szenario ist durchaus interessant.
Das kann ja auch genauso auf die Fertigpizza im Supermarkt, auf der Paybackkarte zutreffen. Das sind alles so Fragen, die natürlich immer so das Horror-Szenario sind, bei diesen ganzen Kundenkarten, Identifikationsgeschichten. Bei der Geldkarte, wie gesagt, wir vertrauen mal darauf, dass sie nicht passiert.
Was lernen wir Johannes? Fertigpizza nicht rauchen. Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 135. Wir reden über Plastikkarten, die ihr mit euch rumführt auf den Magnetstreifen oder Chips oder RFID-Chips oder sonst was drauf ist, auf denen Daten gespeichert sind. Und wo ihr euch vielleicht fragt, was steht da eigentlich drauf? Würde ich immer schon mal gerne wissen. Die Jungs vom CCC können euch da helfen.
Genau, und ich wollte eigentlich nochmal kurz anmerken, dass ihr uns auch per E-Mail erreichen könnt auf chaosradio.de Und ich möchte außerdem noch auf unseren Ableger sozusagen in Chaosradio Express hinweisen, immer mal wieder, wo unsere ganzen oder wo einige unsere Themen und auch viele mehr in aller Tiefe besprochen werden. Das Chaosradio Express macht der Tim hauptsächlich. Das ist nur ein klassischer Podcast, kommt also nicht im Radio. Und ist also die Möglichkeit, mal, wenn ihr bei Themen mal ein bisschen länger hinhören wollt, die sind so meist eine Stunde oder auch mal zwei, wenn man ins Plaudern kommt. Und da sind so die ganzen Sachen, die wir hier eigentlich nur anschneiden können, werden da dann mal in aller Tiefe besprochen.
Wir werden nach den Nachrichten noch aufs Thema Packstation eingehen, auch Karte, die wir noch nicht hatten und natürlich auch Schließsysteme, wie man da so rein und raus kommt. Martin und Manuel wollen was dazu sagen. Jungs, habt ein bisschen Geduld. Wir machen Nachrichten. Danach seid ihr dran.
Fritz präsentiert eine der besten Livebands dieses Planeten. Und Berlins. Und das Abschlusskonzert ihrer Europa Tournee. Fritz präsentiert die Beatstakes. Karten gibt's überall wo's Karten gibt. Und Zusatzkonzerte auf keinen Fall. Dafür aber mehr Infos. Freitag, 29.
August.
Die Beat Stakes.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Und das hört man.
23.32.
CSU-Chef Erwin Huber unterstützt die Forderung der Milchbauer nach einem höheren Milchpreis. Er hatte einen Milchpreis von mehr als 40 Cent für angemessen, sagt er dem Münchner Merkur. Der Bundesverband Deutscher Milchviehhalter fordert einen Basispreis von 42 Cent pro Liter da der Preis für Milch in den letzten Monaten stark gesunken ist. Fast alle Mitglieder des Verbands protestieren nun und haben ihre Milchlieferungen eingestellt. Engpässe in Supermärkten soll es noch nicht geben. Vertreter aus über 100 Ländern haben sich bei einer Konferenz in Dublin auf ein Verbot von Streubomben geeinigt. Die tödlichen Waffen öffnen sich in der Luft und können viele kleine Sprengsets über ein weites Gebiet verteilen. Da diese oftmals nicht sofort detonieren, bleiben sie als Landminen liegen. Die weltweit wichtigsten Produzenten und Anwender von Streubomben, die USA, Israel, China, Russland, Indien und Pakistan, nahmen an der Konferenz allerdings nicht teil. Deutschland will mehr Geld für den Erhalt der tropischen Regenwälder ausgeben. Auf der UNO-Konferenz zum Schutz der Artenvielfalt in Bonn kündigte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel an, die Bundesrepublik werde von 2013 an jährlich eine halbe Milliarde Euro bereitstellen, um das Abholzen der Wälder zu stoppen. Auch andere Industrieländer sollen sich dadurch ermutigt fühlen, sich für den Regenwald in den Entwicklungsländern einzusetzen. Neapel hat sich nach 240 Jahren als Monarchie zur Republik erklärt. Den Beschluss dazu fällt die verfassungsgebende Versammlung. Im künftigen Parlament werden die Maoisten die stärkste Fraktion und somit vermutlich auch den Regierungschef stellen. Sie hatten die Monarchie mit Waffengewalt bekämpft. In dem Konflikt sind in den vergangenen zehn Jahren mehr als 13.000 Menschen getötet worden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Angermünde 13 Grad, Frankfurt 17, Potsdam, Cottbus, Neuropin und Wittenberge 18 Grad und in Berlin um die 18 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenig Wolken, es bleibt meist trocken. Vereinsierte Schauer gibt es nur in Richtung Fleming und Dosse und die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 14 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder schön sonnig, aber mit ein paar Wolken und Regnen soll es dabei nicht. Die Temperaturen steigen auf maximal 25 bis 29 Grad. A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden, zwischen Dreieck Spreewald und Groß-Räschen fährt ein Schwertransport. Überholen ist hier nicht möglich.
Nachrichtenwetterverkehr mit Liane Gruß, vielen Dank.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9?
Dann Fritz rund um Welt sich.
Blumen, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Die junge Frau kommt aus Schweden, heißt Luckeli. Das war der Black Kids Remix. Und die komplette Playliste der Sendung gibt es natürlich auf fritz.de. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio Teil 135 auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Henrik und Frank sind hier. Wir haben noch knapp 20 Minuten Zeit, um über Plastikkarten zu reden, auf denen Daten von euch gespeichert sind, wo ihr immer schon mal fragen wolltet. Was ist das eigentlich? Wir hatten schon die Mensa-Karte, die Karte für den Geldautomaten, die Karten, mit denen man im Bus oder in der Bahn bezahlt per RFID-Chip. Was ist eigentlich mit Rabattkarten, mit so Bank- und Geldkarten? Und Manuel hat noch eine weitere Karte mit ins Spiel einzuwerfen, nämlich die wunderbare Karte der Packstation. Hallo Manuel. Schönen guten Abend.
Du willst wissen, wie die Packstation-Karte funktioniert?
Ja, genau. Also an sich fand ich die Idee von der Packstation eine ganz gute, weil ich dann eben nicht mehr zur Post rennen muss, wenn ich gerade wieder Post verpasst habe.
Es fehlt mir so ein bisschen die automatische Umleitung zur Packstation.
Bitte?
Es fehlt mir so ein bisschen die automatische Umleitung von Paketen an meine Adresse an die Packstation.
Ja gut, wobei das wär dann ja auch nicht unbedingt so praktisch, weil dann wissen wir nicht an welche Packstation. Ich bin ja mal da, mal da. Aber jetzt mal davon abgesehen, mir ist dann ja gleich das Grauen gekommen, als ich den gesamten Prozess da kennengelernt hab, weil einmal, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war meine Handynummer ein absolutes Lichtfeld, als ich mich da angemeldet hab.
Ja, weil die Packstation dir eine SMS schickt, weil sie dir sagte, dein Paket ist da.
Und jetzt hab ich halt da noch eine weitere Karte im Geldbeutel. Im Prinzip weiß ich überhaupt nichts über die Karte, was ist da drauf. Ja, und abgesehen davon, dass ich mir die Pinnig merken kann, wird mich das eben interessieren.
Wie sieht denn die aus? Ist das eine Magnetstreifenkarte oder?
Goldkarte, so eine goldene Karte, hat auch so eine Nummer. Und Magnetstreifen sieht im Prinzip aus wie all diese Kundensammelkarten.
So, hm. Es geprägt hat sogar einen Posthologramm drauf. Die sieht ja gleich aus. Und in Unterschriften fällt da nichts. Ja, Magnetstreifen würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, Magnetstreifen mit PIN. Und eigentlich brauchst du die auch zum einen, um wenn die Parkstation in einem geschlossenen Bereich ist, um in den Bereich reinzukommen.
Ah, wobei es gibt, das haben wir vorhin schon gehört, es gibt Poststellen, da kommst du mit der Parkstationkarte nicht rein, sondern du musst dich entweder per EC oder per Kreditkarte legitimieren, um überhaupt an die Parkstation ranzukommen, wo man sich natürlich die Frage stellen muss, wieso muss ich da zu einer EC-Karte ziehen?
Bei meiner Post war das so, dass man die Karte gar nicht ganz reinstecken konnte und deswegen konntest du Magnetstreifen nicht ganz lesen. Es ging jede Karte mit Magnetstreifen, Hauptdarmagnetstreifen.
Da hast du aber eine glückliche Post gehabt. Ja.
Ja, also im Prinzip würde ich... Wir können jetzt auch nichts Genaues darüber sagen, was da drauf gespeichert ist, oder?
Na, da wird deine Nummer drauf sein und das wird es wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen sein.
Na, da hätte ich noch einen Einwurf, weil es gibt ja auch so private Parkstationen. Also solche, die man nicht über die Post-Webseite findet, wo man praktisch die Nummer wissen muss und nur dann da hinschicken kann. Also zum Beispiel bei meiner Firma im Keller steht auch so eine Parkstation.
So eine Art Postfach.
Die ist nur für die Mitarbeiter gedacht. Und da würde mich jetzt natürlich interessieren, ob man praktisch nur die Nummer wissen muss, um die dahin zu senden, oder ob ich jetzt auch eine Parkstationkarte brauche, eine spezielle, und ob da praktisch zum Beispiel mein Arbeitgeber drauf gespeichert ist.
Na, ich würde jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig ins Dunkel hinein theoretisieren. Also wo das Paket hingeschickt wird, ist ja im Endeffekt egal. Wenn du es nicht abholen kannst und die Karte nicht hast, schicken sie sie einfach wieder zurück und melden sich dann irgendwie nochmal bei dir. Und wenn du eine Parkstation, eine private, bei dir bei deinem Arbeitgeber hast, dann ist ja klar, dass die bei deinem Arbeitgeber steht, weil da steht ja dann nicht drauf irgendwie Michael Müller, sondern Wasserfirma XY, Parkstation Nummer, und dann kommt irgendeine Zahl. Da steht ja vorne schon obendrauf, wo diese Parkstation steht. Also da glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendwie ein Problem geben würde. Aber wie gesagt, es ist absolut gefährliches Halbwissen. Das vermute ich jetzt einfach nur.
Also ich habe auf die Schnelle auch irgendwie gerade nichts im Netz gefunden. Kann mir zwar nicht vorstellen, dass sich das noch niemand angesehen hat in Magnetstreifen, aber wir werden das mal bei Gelegenheit tun.
Wir haben ein Auge drauf.
Genau, schick uns mal, wenn du es wissen willst, schick uns mal eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Kann aber irgendwie ein, zwei Wochen dauern.
Parkstation hätten wir erklärt, was wir auf gar keinen Fall noch vergessen sollten, ist das Thema Schließsysteme und so Eingangskarten, wenn man irgendwo in einen speziellen Raum will. So was zum Beispiel dazu hat Martin angerufen. Hallo Martin. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Dresden, alles klar. Oh, da findet ja, kann man gleich nochmal sagen, in Dresden findet ja am kommenden Wochenende Datenspuren statt.
Nicht kommendes Wochenende, ein später, am 7. 8. Juni.
Bei mir, ja stimmt.
Genau, also 10 Tagen sozusagen, genau, in der Scheune. Irgendwie von morgens bis abends, kostet nichts. Und da gibt es irgendwie CCC-Vorträge.
Und da kommt man aber auch nur rein, wenn man eine Zugangskarte hat. Nein, Quatsch. Martin, was hast du mit dem Schließsystem für ein Problem?
So, also vor etwas längerer Zeit habe ich mal ein Praktikum gemacht bei einem großen deutschen Elektronikkonzern. Und habe ich einen Mitarbeiterausweis bekommen. Und den Ausweis brauchte ich, um zu meinem Arbeitsplatz zu kommen. Der war in so einem Sicherheitsbereich. Jetzt nicht irgendwie, weil da ein Reaktor in der Nähe steht oder so, sondern einfach nur, weil die ein bisschen Angst vor Industriespionage hatten. Jedenfalls musste ich dann halt immer, um zu meinem Arbeitsplatz zu kommen, durch so eine große schwere Staltür durch, die sich nur eröffnete, wenn ich dann mein Mitarbeiterausweis an so ein Lesegerät gehalten habe. Also es war vermutlich mal AFID. Der Trick am Ganzen war jetzt, dass die Toilette befand sich zum Beispiel außerhalb dieses Sicherheitsbereiches. So, dass ich immer irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, dass mein Arbeitgeber dann auch sehr genau protokolliert, wann ich dann nun auf Toilette gehe oder rausgehe, eine rauchen oder halt zum Mittagessen gehe. Und das finde ich jetzt nicht so toll.
Also normalerweise gibt es ja sowas wie Stechuhren in so ganzes Althergebracht betrieben. Das ist bei so Großfirmen, die es ja offensichtlich geht, ist es eine Sache, die auch die Arbeitnehmervertretung, also sprich der Betriebsrat, dann auch zumindest ein Wörtchen mitzureden hat und auch darüber informiert wird, was da genau ist. Und so Sachen kannst du dann auch nachfragen beim Betriebsrat. Und damit machst du dich dann auch irgendwie nicht verdächtig. Also eigentlich, wenn der Betriebsrat wirklich vertrauenswürdig ist, dann ist es auch kein Problem, dass du danach fragst, wie ist das, was wird denn eigentlich gespeichert? Und die sollten in der Lage sein, dir darüber Auskunft zu geben. Also diese Zutrittskarten gibt es eigentlich bei vielen großen Firmen. Da wird dann wahrscheinlich schon registriert, wer wann durch welche Tür gegangen ist. Allein wenn jetzt irgendwo, keine Ahnung, dann doch mal irgendwo was geklaut wird, in ein Büro oder sowas, dann kann man sehen, wer von den Mitarbeitern potenziell da jetzt in dem Bereich ist. Das ist natürlich ziemlich heikel, weil, ja, wer sagt denn, dass ich da denn wirklich war? Also nur, dass meine Kartenkennung da in diesem Lesingerät gelandet ist, heißt ja nicht, dass ich oder überhaupt nur meine Karte da tatsächlich auch gewesen ist.
Naja, zu den Berufen gibt es ja aber, wenn das wirklich Hochsicherheitsbereiche sind, gibt es ja meistens auch eine Kamera, die da hängt, die das zusätzlich beobachtet.
Ja, also im Zweifelsfall sieht ihr dann auch nur, dass du irgendwie eine Nase und irgendwie zwei Ohren hast. Also diese RFID Geschichten, die sind, die sind oftmals nicht so sicher wie die Verkäufer, die einem so ein System aufspatzen überhaupten. Da haben wir ja schon irgendwie einiges gehabt. Klassikerweise oder der wahrscheinlich schlimmste Fall, in Anführungszeichen, war die Geschichte um MyFair. Es gibt aber auch andere Systeme, die viel einfacher sind, welche quasi gar keine oder praktisch gar keine Verschlüsselung haben, die man irgendwie mit einem iPod quasi oder mit einem MP3-Player.
Gar keine Verschlüsselung ist sehr, sehr weit verbreitet. Ich hatte das bei mir an der Uni. Da hatten wir ein sehr altes, naja gut, sehr altes System aus 1998 von der Firma NEDAP, was aber eher so nach 80er-Jahre-Technologie aussah. Einfache weiße Karten, die, wenn sie in das Lesegerät erzeugt, erzeugt ein Magnetfeld, ein wechselndes Magnetfeld. Wenn man die Karte reinhält, dann fängt sie an, ihre Identifikationsnummer rauszusenden. Was einen schon einmal hätte stutzig machen sollen, ist, dass es die Lesegeräte von derselben Firma auch im drei Meter reichweiten Bereich gibt, sodass man einfach bloß auf die Tür zugehen muss, damit sie anfängt, sich zu öffnen. Was vielleicht jemand, der das kauft, so ein bisschen hätte stutzig machen können. Ich hab mir das mal angesehen und so rausgefunden, dass es wirklich nur die Nummer sendet, hab die Nummer dann aufgezeichnet auf ein beliebiges Audiogerät, weil die mit sehr geringer Bitrate gesendet wurde, also ein iPod zum Beispiel. Und hab dann eine einfache Kartenattrappe gebaut, also sieht nicht mal so ähnlich aus wie eine Karte, sondern einfach bloß eine Spule mit drei Bauteilen dran, an den iPod anschließen, die richtige Audiodatei abspielen und die Tür öffnet sich. Das sind die ganz einfachen Systeme, die nur eine Nummer auslesen. Das ist erstaunlich weit verbreitet oder erschreckend weit verbreitet. Wir haben in dem anderen Gebäude der Universität auch so ein Schließkartensystem, was dann auf Myfair basiert. Myfair hat eigentlich Sicherheitsfunktionen, die in dem System aber nicht weiter verwendet werden. Es liest einfach auch bloß die Nummer aus. Da ist dann die Schaltung nicht mehr nur 3 Euro teuer, sondern 40 Euro teuer. Man kann es trotzdem sehr einfach umgehen. Dann gibt es Systeme, die mit Verschlüsselung arbeiten, wo zum Beispiel das Lesegerät was zur Karte hinschickt. Die Karte muss dann mit einer verschlüsselten Version davon antworten. Da ist, weil die preiswert sein sollen, baut man dann meistens nicht ordentliche Verschlüsselung ein, sondern irgendwas, was man sich beim Frühstück selber ausgedacht hat. In Amerika ist es vielen Leuten auf die Füße gefallen, mit dem Texas Instruments Digital Signature Transponder. Da hat sich eine Forschergruppe hingesetzt und einfach mal herausgefunden, wie das Ding funktioniert und konnte sie danach machen. Sehr gerne eingesetzt bei zum Beispiel Wegfahrsperren, also Autos, ist im Prinzip auch ein Zugangskontrollsystem.
Aber auch an Tankstellen in den USA.
Genau. Und die andere Sache ist dann MyFair. Da ist schon ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit drin. Da ist der Schlüssel etwas länger. Das Verfahren ist auch nicht bekannt, war nicht bekannt. Wir haben es Ende des letzten Jahres veröffentlicht und da hat sich eine Forschergruppe in den Niederlanden hingesetzt, hat da ein bisschen weiter aufbauend auf unseren Ergebnissen weitergeforscht. Und dahin ist dann aufgefallen, dass das Schließkartensystem, was das niederländische Verteidigungsministerium und Innenministerium überall einsetzt, schwere Probleme hat bei der Implementierung dieses Verfahrens, sodass man einfach bloß an ein Lesegerät rangehen konnte. Man hält dann so eine falsche Karte davor, lässt sie ein bisschen was tun, setzt sich wieder zurück, trinkt einen Tee während der Computer ein bisschen rechnet und kann anschließend das Schließkartensystem umgehen. Als sie das dann dem niederländischen Inlandsgeheimdienst vorgestellt haben, ist das Innenministerium so ein bisschen nervös geworden, hat erstmal in den wichtigsten Bereichen bewaffnete Zusatzfachen aufgestellt.
Es gibt Dinge, die man eigentlich gar nicht im Detail wissen will.
Und dann gibt es sehr selten auch Systeme, die mit ordentlicher Verschlüsselung arbeiten.
Martin, danke für den Anruf. Uns läuft nämlich ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg. Wir haben jetzt über Packstationen noch geredet, über Schließsysteme. Wir wollen auf jeden Fall noch das Thema SIM-Karten ansprechen.
SIM-Karten, genau. Das sind die kleinen Dinge, die ein Telefon hat.
Die im Wesentlichen dafür, also die erste breite Anwendung einer Smartcard waren. Und zur weltweiten Verbreitung.
Wie heißen die?
Subscriber Identity Multimodule.
Genau. Und das sind eigentlich ganz normale Chip-Karten oder ganz normale Karten. Nur, ihr kennt es ja, wenn ihr die neu bekommen habt, dann brecht ihr die einfach raus. Also die sind einfach von der Größe her kleiner, weil der Chip auf so einer Telefonkarte oder auf irgendeiner, was auch immer, Karte, der ist eigentlich auch nur so groß, wie der Chip ist oder nie. Es ist viel, viel kleiner, der eigentlich die Chip, das Große nur die Kontakte, womit man das Ding dann ins Gerät reinstecken kann, womit die Kontakte hergestellt werden. Deswegen sind diese SIM-Karten für Telefone so klein.
Die waren früher mal größer. Früher hatten die richtig die große Form, wie heute der Führerschein, also das ID.1-Format.
Das waren dann noch die Auto-Telefone.
Ja, das war eigentlich so gedacht, dass die Handys teuer werden sollen und man dann halt einfach für jedes Familienmitglied so eine SIM-Karte hat und dann ständig die SIM-Karten wechselt. Deswegen waren die so groß und meistens der SIM-Karten-Slot auch noch von außen zugänglich. Die Preisentwicklung bei Handys hat sich dann so ein bisschen anders entwickelt. Deswegen sind die heute immer in kleiner Form zum reinstecken. Die Amerikaner haben das gleich weggelassen, die SIM-Karten. Da ist dann die Nummer an das Handy gebunden.
Ja, was es drin ist, ist eine Kartennummer. Ich bin da ein bisschen überfordert.
Es ist eine richtige Smartcard. Das heißt, sie hat Kryptografiefunktionen, leichte zumindest mit einem besonderen Algorithmus. Sie hat eine PIN und überprüft auch einen Fehlbedienungszähler. Man hat nur so und so viele Versuche, die PIN einzugeben, bevor sie gesperrt wird. Man kann da drin Telefonbucheinträge speichern, eine Handvoll. Man kann da drin SMS speichern, eine Handvoll Ein- und Ausgehende. Und die Karte überprüft dann, also man muss halt die PIN eingeben, wenn es dann eingestellt ist. Man kann auch die PIN-Prüfung abschalten, bevor man auf die Telefonbucheinträge oder die SMS zugreifen kann. Und die besondere Funktionalität, wofür das Ding eigentlich da ist, dass da ein Schlüssel drin ist, ein Geheimer, ein symmetrischer Schlüssel. Und ein Geheimer, oder zumindest früher Geheimer Algorithmus, Krypto-Algorithmus, Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus ist drin, mit dem sich dann die SIM-Karte gegenüber dem Netzwerk, also es gibt dann ein Gegenstück irgendwo bei deinem Netzbetreiber, gegen den sich dann die SIM-Karte authentisiert, damit dann der Netzbetreiber weiß, das ist jetzt die echte SIM-Karte und die darf jetzt telefonieren.
Haben wir sonst noch in irgendeiner Form eine Karte vergessen, die wir zu erwähnen hätten von der großen Liste? Wir hatten krass mal zusammen, worüber wir geredet haben, heute im Chaos Radio, über Mensa-Karten, über Karten am Geldautomat, über EC-Karten, über die Karten im Verkehrsverbund, die zum Busticket kaufen zum Beispiel zu benutzen sind. Wir haben über die Problematik gesprochen, sich zu legitimieren, zum Beispiel an irgendeinem Verkaufsautomat, sei es ein Zigarettenautomat oder was auch immer, welche Daten speichern die da, über Rabattkarten, was steht auf diesen Dingern eigentlich drauf. Wir hatten die Packstation, wir hatten Zugangskarten, wir haben über SIM-Karten geredet. Hier steht noch auf der großen Liste Videotheken. Dann steht hier noch Mitgliederausweise. Und hier steht noch Hoteltür.
Hoteltür, da hat irgendwie keiner zu angerufen. Wir haben es von uns aus auch nicht geschafft. Da gibt es ziemlich viele verschiedene Systeme. Am weitesten verbreitesten sind eigentlich die Magnetkarten, würde ich mal sagen, oder sehr verbreitet. Und da ist es in der Regel so, dass da eine Zimmernummer und ein Checkout-Datum, also bis wann man das Zimmer gebucht hat, draufgeschrieben ist. Und dann steckt man ja einfach in diese Tür rein, in das Lesegerät. Und das Lesegerät hat dann irgendwie eine Uhr drinne und sieht dann, aha, okay, der darf hier rein. Und es gibt da ein paar Systeme, die ein bisschen sophisticated sind, dass man also nicht einfach auf gut Glück von irgendjemanden eine Karte nehmen kann, die kopieren kann. Ich kann es mir jetzt gerade nicht zusammenreiben, wie das funktioniert. Die haben sich da was ausgedacht, dass es gehen soll.
Also es wird dann zum Beispiel in Karte und Schloss ein Zähler hochgezählt und dann der Zähler nicht übereinstimmt. Das heißt aber nicht, dass man die Karte nicht kopieren kann, sondern das heißt bloß, dass eine von den beiden Karten funktioniert. Wenn ich mit meiner kopierten Karte der erste bin, der das Hotelzimmer betritt, dann funktioniert nur meine Karte und nicht die echte.
Richtig, genau. Ja, was haben wir noch? Wir haben eine ganze Liste. Ich glaube, wir sind aber so die wichtigsten.
Wir sind die wichtigsten, glaube ich, durchgegangen.
Genau, also noch mal Chaosradio at ccc.de. Ja, wenn ihr da irgendwie noch Fragen habt, schreibt uns das ansonsten auch noch mal der Verweis auf das Wiki, auf die Mitmachs-Seite zur Sendung. Alles abzurufen unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ich bleibe vielleicht als Fazit zu sagen, Magnetstreifenkarten, wie ihr vorhin schon mal erwähnt habt, sind eigentlich seit über vier Jahren locker überfällig.
Seit vielen Jahren, seit ungefähr 30.
Seit über 30 Jahren, das ist was auch länger als faires. Seit langer Zeit überfällig, alt hergebracht und vollkommen unsicher, dass die Karten mit dem Chip irgendwann kommen sollen. Da wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen was passieren, bis die Banken alle sagen, das bringen wir mal ein. Und wir haben nicht viel mehr außer dem Rat für euch. Passt auf euren Kram auf und schreibt die Nummer nicht da auf die Karten.
Aufpassen, wo er jetzt reinsteckt.
Steht überall.
Und vielleicht beim Pin eingeben dann doch mal das Portemonnaie oder die andere Hand drüber halten. Das macht auch schon mal eine ganze Menge aus.
Wollten wir ganz kurz vielleicht nochmal zu erwähnen, wie das mit den RFID-Karten ist und der Privacy Card von Philwood?
Die Privacy Card von Philwood, das ist eine Sache, die ist glaube ich schon, das ist vor ein paar Jahren gelaufen, das ist jetzt durch. Findet ihr unter Privacy Card und vielleicht Payback oder so im Netz. Google ist da oder eure Suchmaschine der Wahl ist da mal eine ganz große Hilfe, wenn es darum geht, mal rauszufinden. Machen wir eigentlich auch nicht anders, wenn wir eine komische Karte haben. Wir gucken, wer ist der Hersteller? Magnetstreifen als Suchwort oder Chip oder sowas. Und oftmals findet da, findet man schon eine ganze Menge da. Und ansonsten schreibt er uns eine Mail.
Und bei neuen Entwicklungen mehr dann dazu an dieser Stelle. Das war's Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 135 am 28. Mai 2008. Hier geht's weiter mit Maxwell Smart und einem fantastischen Liveflight mit Beats, die ihr noch nie gehört habt in eurem Leben und die auch er noch nie gehört hat in seinem Leben und die so krass sind, dass er da draußen schon anfängt zu Breakdancen. Henrik, Franco und Jakob Kranz sagen Tschüss. Bis dann, machts gut.